all right and we
are live the last word with laura
cognito and ivantas
fresh on that friday campfire vibe
kind of feel like we got something
special going on today eos what's going
on today man yeah if you guys are
catching this on audio make sure you
guys catch the video because that we're
gonna be look talking with an awesome
artist today and the backgrounds are
gonna be all from him so
cognito back to you let's bring this man
in the only way we know how see if we
can make him blush
you already know welcome to the last
word
episode number 117 and it's another
glorious friday we're back in front of
the campfire for some more lunar shooter
discussion
i'm extremely excited about a special
guest so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only proficient in the world digital
artistry but with his smooth teaching
style
and versatile creations truly merged the
law of destiny
with an amazing visual aesthetic
introducing the digital artist creator
and host of the gamma trap youtube and
twitch channels
the dark knight himself glasses inquirer
on stream
and when that starting soon intro hit
you already know
you're in the trap house
from ibotta state of texas and kind
enough to make his debut
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord gamma trap how you doing sir
i'm doing great what a d you guys are i
don't know how you guys hit this level
of intro every single time with every
person right
every single one i've seen it's always
been like bam bam
he lines him up he gives him the two hit
combo leads ducks
nice man we gotta get you right by the
campfire we gotta cheat you right man
how you doing man
i'm getting doing great and you when you
said the trap house thing and just
did for those who are unaware there's
another target for that but
i thought it was funny as hell because
i've been trying to make that a clan for
the longest time it's so
funny if you got your grand name to trap
house funny as hell that'd be awesome
be way too fitting what is going on
man long overdue good to have you back
actually for the first time you did you
but um watch what you've been playing
and stuff like that i'll let you take
over because you know i got a thousand
questions
we got to get to know this man first
obviously um
but i just gotta like in case people
don't know i got the little uh
little bit behind your name but i was
like i want more people to know where
the name game of trap come
comes from because they might not know
they may have some idea but
let the world know where'd the name come
from first i just thought it was kind of
a cool little story
well let me see turn this light down a
bit
um it came from
i was 11 and i liked to draw and i was
horrible at it
and i made a little comic book and main
character's name was gamma trap because
he would make little
little little ambush things because he
would trap
uh space pirates and an asteroid belt
and with these little gamma bombs
this sounds like they ruin this effigy
[Laughter]
i was just visualizing it i was like
this little ball in the game continue
i'm sorry
maybe i should maybe i should actually
play the game to get that gun
there you go still haven't still don't
have it yet well you know eventually
you'll get there so
yeah dude you'll you'll love it it
actually conceptually kind of fits with
you
it literally fits what you described
like basically collapses people into
this little void orb as you kill them
i mean i know what the gun does
man anyway but that's pretty much it and
honestly the name gamma trap
before that came from uh because again i
was 11
not very creative because i was 11. uh
the incredibles
had this bonus feature where it showed
you other superheroes in the area which
is why it made me
have the idea of doing a superhero thing
in the first place
and one of those characters name was
gamma jack who could like
shoot laser beams and i was like that's
not as cool as
in my opinion so being 11.
you're like i wasn't too worried about
ip infringement at all
hey come on because they're totally
different you guys could exist in the
same space
exactly no problem look i had a you know
trapping jackets all good man
no doubt no doubt so one thing like i
said one thing i notice about you is
that i thought it's real cool besides
you know your artistry and stuff
is that you actually teach like
most people i would say i call it giving
game like you actually people who
inspire kind of getting you feel like
what
inspired you to kind of go that route
with that part of your content creation
and
just showing people you know how to do
things money
what's up apple how you doing over there
i've always had this like uh philosophy
that the whole rising tides lift all
boats kind of thing
so a lot of the people that actually
watch my
tutorials and and partake in any of that
are people that are kind of in my little
zone my little sphere of
of of other creators and stuff so
if i teach them what i know at the
moment and what i figured out
right then we'll all sort of
kind of rise together sort of thing
absolutely
so i i try and give this information out
to people who could like
help me get better that's cool that's
cool
respect it respect yeah because like i
said i i don't i guess i don't see that
often or maybe i don't know
in your field like i said something i
don't see a lot but i always thought
that was cool and
checking out your work i was like wow
that's cool he's actually telling people
how to color stuff in how to
you know use the digital artistry and
stuff like that i thought it was pretty
dope so
i got more stuff you better keep coming
man
no i kind of want to ask you i know you
said um just kind of your history in the
world of like obviously
you know been into all this type of
stuff since you were like 11 or younger
gaming things like that
and i know you mentioned a couple games
that have like really cool stories like
halo and spyro and stuff like that and
kind of curious
as like story is one of those important
pieces to you
is that one of those things is that the
bigger piece that hooked you into
destiny or was that the gameplay like
halo first which one
caught you first being of destiny it was
definitely the story
okay i didn't play destiny until i've
already watched almost
all the lore videos of like sir wallin
i watched a bunch of milan and stuff and
i saw a couple of biff but like earlier
on
he just i don't i don't know when he
started but he wasn't
he wasn't as prevalent at the moment as
like sir wallin was like the lord
yeah and then exactly mylan was there
but like anyway so i
knew the story like i knew almost
everything about
like all this like you know sorrow and
you know book of sorrow stuff and like
oh i'm getting a little tongue-tied here
but like the
the story of destiny was so huge and
there was just such a huge access of the
grimoire cards back on that website
yes um like knowing the story going in
i didn't see what everyone was
complaining about
story this is awesome right yeah because
i knew the whole because of my
my experience was enriched right you
know before i even
shot a gun at all so because i knew like
i'd walk in i'd go to locations i'd see
this stuff and i'd be like
oh wait hang on you know like
immediately
and like i was at gamestop
getting the game and getting like an
external hard drive for my
xbox um and and like i was like
destiny you know because tayden king
just came out and put them on the table
and like one of the other people that
are there i think it was like someone
who worked there was like
i mean you don't i'm just gonna let you
know you totally get this i think it's
gonna be i think you have a great time
for a little while but like i beat the
thing in an hour and i just returned it
oh and i was like okay trying to give
you that regret
kind of set you up yeah yeah so i was
like okay i mean i'll
i'll try it if i don't like it i'll turn
and he's like
i had never returned it that's so funny
you said that because
you know from as a destiny fan it's kind
of the same thing like
a lot of us realize there is so much
lore there but at the time everything
you know was buried in the grimoire
and the running joke from fanboys was
like destiny has no story like why would
you like that
you know saying so it's funny to hear
you say that because that is actually a
good
point about destiny like if you actually
pay attention you do research and again
that was just the issue just everything
was buried in the grimoire but it was
amazing amazing
stories man i think he was yeah i think
it was the same issue
because they were highly inspired by
from software's work with dark souls and
demon souls and stuff so
that was an extraordinarily visual
storytelling of
of everything everywhere you went within
those games you would see
like oh there's a person that's that's
an enemy that's just like those enemies
but this one
has a strange you know backpack and you
know just every little detail is just
just scattered throughout the game and
so they
wanted to put information in the item
descriptions
in basic stuff but like the resources i
think at the time they had they just
couldn't
accomplish the same but it had a wider
appeal
than the dark souls games at the time no
it was like it attracted the halo
players and
if even if those players like played
dark souls they probably picked it up
put it right back down because just won
their cup of tea
so when they got to destiny they were
like oh that's a cool gun play but i
mean there's
nothing here i'm used to halo
storytelling
where they you know it's a roller
coaster and because it's an online
multiplayer game the roller coasters
don't exactly work the same
true absolutely that's kind of what i
was going to actually ask is there
as story is such a big thing and
obviously your appreciation for it is on
a different level from most
is there a balance from what you could
guess what their resources are besides
what they do now i mean they've got the
the books that come in the game would
you like to see because i've been
playing a ghost of tsushima
and they'll do like they have four like
legendary
things that you can go through and they
do these kind of like
not storyboard but kind of like animated
storyboards
just kind of a way to do like hey give a
little description like couple
concept art pieces and talk over it with
something would you like to see some of
that or is that more of the
is that too much do you think just in
your face no i i would love to see it
okay i mean more story is always good in
my opinion right right
resources wise it's not that difficult
like to accomplish like i could do
i could by myself i could make something
like that in about a month
okay per story thing yeah if i heard
that
if that was my only project if that's
what i was doing boom boom boom i can
make one a month
you know but it does require like a bit
of work and i
i want them everyone's always like
bungee fix your game you know getting
all salty and freaking
you know reddit about it all okay and
yeah and um so i mean they're they're
constantly torn the resources go towards
fixing the balance and making it more
fun for people who don't really care
about the story
or do they want to add the story so it's
this weird
fight a lot of people it's gonna be
weird okay a lot of people
are like torn between fixing the gun
play because they don't care about story
right versus adding story because they
don't
care too much about pvp and gun playing
balance and sandbox and stuff and then
there's also the people who are like
yeah
just go full mmo just like just give us
those quality of life things like
trading and and like crafting your own
stuff that you can use in a raid or
just like world of warcraft stuff so
they're i don't know their resources are
stretch pretty thin if they're trying to
accomplish a little bit of all that
yeah that's a good point it's a good
point definitely a community
we're a bit demanding and uh we have a
lot of different groups that uh
yell for specific things i would agree
would agree with that
hard to balance them all but overall
they do a decent job at trying to
they do a decent job but that's kind of
thing is like if you want to go
focus on one thing it's hard for them
they're a jack of all trades hard to be
a master of all
at that point yeah true total i gotta
get that tram talk about scrap pvp watch
your mouth
anyway oh muno i'm i'm of a weird view
on that one actually
yeah well you were doing good you were
doing good okay okay okay
i practically i know this will never
happen
but what i would love to see is if they
actually separated pvp from the game
not in a bad way i want them to be still
kind of connected
but it's going to go along with my what
i want for the vault by the way the dcv
you're going pvp we're going to vote my
p okay no no no
i want the pvp to be playable at all
times free to play same as it's going
right now
but i want it to be like a separate
almost a separate game
because sort of like um yeah i'm not not
not going to say disc but like imagine
titanfall and apex same
universe the same thing's going on apex
is free to play
and we just jump in play your stuff but
it's not it's a br it's not like it's a
arena kind of thing right and then
titanfall it's it's got pvp it's got its
own thing but it's not
apex you know right same guns same world
same story a lot of the same characters
it's just different [ __ ]
so logistics is from a balance
standpoint so it would be separate
and that way what's your goal okay
that's why i want to see where you're
going with it i would love to see
the pvp be as a balanced and competitive
as pos i don't know i don't want to
swear too much balanced and competitive
as possible
meaning that no random roles they'll fix
everyone gets the same stuff got you
okay i see where you going keep the
abilities keep it destiny but you know
right yes and and only so many guns
so many autos so many pulses so many
hand cans everyone has access to it you
can change it up in the menu screen
before you go in
okay and you you earn aesthetic rewards
and stuff that you do in the main game
of destiny would link back and give you
extra aesthetic rewards in the pvp mode
maybe i don't know you know it'd be
interesting i'd love to see it
but it practically will never happen
their whole mentality of like taking
this gun that i earned over here in the
raid i wanted to feel the exact same way
in pvp and i was like then you have to
bet then
and that's the issue we've had this it's
felt like this year
when you go in the garden of salvation
i'm like these raid weapons
like don't feel hardly any different
than like the hand cannon from
a public event or from gambit or from
and just the in-game rewards and stuff
like that on both sides i definitely
would love to see them
be able to make a bit more game breaking
pve weapons
that don't mess with pvp yeah and it's
like i
a lot of my friends a lot of your
friends and stuff are all like hardcore
pvp sweats
that's their thing professionally they
stream that every day
and that's their livelihood and they
have a great time doing it or they hate
love they do they hate love doing it and
like if we can
actually like give those people a chance
to like have
real competitions right you know like
that'd be
that'd be nice in my opinion i feel you
going with it
let's see where you're going all right
all right got a little disagreement
there but i i see the vision
it's a little good man it's all good but
what i'll ask you is obviously you know
coming across your work um one thing
that's cool it's obviously we talked
about the law
the merging of that and stuff like that
your your attraction to it
but then obviously most people associate
you at least when i came across you was
actually milan
and and seeing that didn't go together
so like tell me about that collaboration
you guys
linking up work with him and then first
of all salute that's zavala the betrayer
y'all just dropped oh yeah
perspective that all that time i thought
it was shax
that was getting influenced now i'm
seeing zavasa i'm all intrigued by this
that i saw your art the
demons going on fire so let's talk about
that and obviously the
myelin connection about the whole you
think it's shaq's like that's that's
kind of like the i think what's
the red herring yeah yeah that on car
skulls next to shacks
but it's looking right at zavala's
office yes
yes it's a weird thing but um so the
mash-up
happened years ago back in rise of iron
right so i've been playing destiny for
an expansion because i got there like
mid taking game
gotcha and um
i was practicing artwork because i was
bad at it
and uh food today
[Laughter]
don't worry at some
yeah so i made this piece of
mountains and and snow and and
kind of like busted up cars and stuff
and it was it was what's a technique
called photo bashing that's what i was
practicing
okay and photo bashing is a technique
that is used by industry professionals
concept artists and illustrators in the
actual game industry
uh where you take actual photos of real
things
and you paint over them as well and you
combine these different photos and
elements
and 3d uh modeling like from like
maya or blender or something like that
and they combine like it's it's a huge
mashup of all these other things to
create this this very fleshed out
piece right so it's like a multimedia
thing
so i was practicing that and i put on
twitter and i tagged
sir wallin and milo and i was like hey
guys what do you think just
you know yeah curious at all right
because the rise environment was going
all the time and mylan was like
can i use that i was like yeah sure if
you need anything else let me know
all right cool and so the next week he
emailed me back and he's like hey
uh i can't find a uh a picture of
this could you would you be interested
in drawing that i'm like yeah sure so i
drew that
anything else let me know all right cool
next week hey um
and it just continued immediately after
that the
just just every single and i was
i was happy about it he didn't pay me
for like a solid year and a half i
wouldn't take anyone he wanted to pay me
but i wouldn't let him oh wow because i
was i was using that as like a vehicle
to practice
because he was giving me new assignments
and stuff every every everyone
okay let's buckle down here i got the
assignment due tomorrow
yeah i was like i'm bad at this i'm i'm
not
anywhere near i want to where i want to
be so i was like you know what i'm just
going to
yeah let me know he was like all right
cool
that's that's what's up man that is cool
that's a cool collaboration so then you
just kind of just kept building where
they kept building it now you you've
been hard on yourself like you're saying
like you you weren't good like a lot of
the early stuff still
fire man like so like what what what do
you consider like
you know you making a step improving on
that journey
while you're working with him well
seeing as i've been teaching this stuff
for a while i can i can spot it and
demonstrate it pretty good now at this
point but
every little step of improvement
is is is is very very small
right so for example if i don't think
i'm good with postures
or like the opposing of anything right
what i'll do for every piece is if i
think i'm not good at something
at the moment i need to do fifty percent
something i am good at and fifty percent
of the piece i will do
that i'm not it's like one piece half
it's gonna be something i'm pretty good
at in half it's gonna be something i'm
not good at
got you roughly so i try and make sure
that every little thing
still looks good but helps me improve
just a little bit
okay uh self-imposed challenge in a way
yeah exactly every little piece is a
little challenge
so if if you're not good at textures or
if you want to work on textures you got
to find an excuse to put that into the
piece
and because i'm just going to call him
matt because i've always called him
um milan
because um he always he's always have
like free range
he he's he's we've experimented on the
best ways
to make the most accurate or useful
visualization of the lore for the video
to make help help it like be a vehicle
for the people
to then like okay i've always explained
it like this
my artwork for the lore videos are like
i built
the uh the car a little cart
that then goes on to the tracks for the
roller coaster
he lays down the tracks i built the car
yeah in the beginning of every little
video of ours it has that work
that sets the tone and then he takes us
through the little story right
so he's like at this point he's like hey
uh this next video is gonna be about
zavala
being up in his feelings and uh he's
he's going to be
he's not necessarily a good guy at the
moment he's
not looking to be a good guy in the
future
so yeah so he'll give me like just a
little bit of information
as little as he as he can oh okay if i
have questions
like okay so you know yeah that stuff
asking for your interpretation without
giving you
all the guidance to be like all right i
want to see where your artist brighton
takes this and he's going to tell them
sorry about it that's
good we've and we've tried it the other
way around you know we've tried
like but we've both been yes to this
entire thing like he's been like hey
uh okay so how about we get so and so
doing so and so running around with so
and so i think i'm thinking a cool
camera like this and yeah we'll try it
and i do it and i post it and it's like
and he's like all right well um
like the video will like kind of like or
people like in the comments just like
blast the artwork and they'll do it to
things that i have complete control over
as well
but he you know we learned that i get
more excited whenever i organically
create something
from like my own thing but as well as
like i probably have a better
understanding as to what looks good
gotcha and he's like i'm never gonna
like
i'm never gonna tell him how to research
anything because this guy's like
almost a phd facts facts facts facts
that's so bad that's cool process cool
process you gotta eat
uh i've just been kind of cycling
through the artwork and stuff like that
i know there's a point just following
you on twitter and everything
you said you made a shift in your style
oh yeah i always make shifts my style
so like can you explain like i guess
whatever the reason what
couple major shifts in style what does
that mean to you and what does that kind
of entails like
how much goes into that like why just
kind of
just like the shift in style like all
that goes into why that happens
okay well again with the whole teaching
thing i've i've always kind of advocated
that artists
change up as much stuff as possible at
all
not not all the time but like you know
enough
a good bit so
to to get big as an artist nowadays on
your own not really with anything just
you're doing your own thing
right on instagram or twitter or any of
this other stuff it's it's people
consistency is key so if you have a set
style
and people know it right
then you're just going to blow up like
crazy especially if they enjoy it right
right
like there's people with over a million
followers and stuff on instagram and
on and they they just draw the same kind
of style and stuff just
just two or three times a day and it's
great it's easy
um problem is with that
it kind of handicaps you a little bit in
my opinion
so if you want to get like
doing a different style not only helps
you learn uh different techniques
but also helps you learn or master
current information that you have
because you're coming at a different
angle just by virtue of doing a
different style
right if you were good at drawing trees
but now you started doing charcoal style
or
painting style or anything like that
then and you when you work on trees with
that drawing knowledge
you just get like 50 better at drawing
trees because you're doing it at this
different way so
i used to do more photorealistic stuff
and uh i hated it because everyone just
thought it was screenshots
got you and they would just scroll by
and i was like all right you're like
that's a compliment but thanks
yeah thanks
so then this is like two three two three
years ago or something
i i more stylized like fluid kind of
exaggerated kind of almost cartoony
style yes
and um i was gonna say i'm gonna put one
up that shows it i think kind of well
that i think cognito will appreciate
oh
oh that that was funny as i got that you
know what's crazy being used for
i got that on my other screen right now
question about speedpaint oh you won't
that's my guy that's your boy
that's forgot that as a metal displayed
right on my wall
it's nice to have quality swimming
anyway
it's like nothing big deal excuse me
hold on ah man
spread the dirt off the soda right quick
let's go it's tough being amazing
anyways continue
all right your weight on my shoulders is
immense
you would win you would be great at an
accepting speech
this one winning an award would be
classic continue
so um yeah so that that's a fact thank
you
that's a perfect demonstration what i
was talking about so this
is more like league of legends splash
art stuff
yes right i
love that style love it to death but
i started like you know i started doing
this style
like two years ago maybe a year and a
half i think maybe you know a year and a
half two years ago and
it's i got to a point where i could do
that so i mean i'm
i'm i'm not you're never done but you
know like i've gotten proud enough of it
that
i'm willing to now move okay okay
fair enough it's it's an interesting
mindset because
one would think that like you know
people get kind of locked into their
zone and
and maybe their fan base kind of you
know
get so used to that stuff like did you
get any
um just to add on an e's question like
did you get any pushback from your base
like
uh we don't we don't like that we want
the old stuff like why are you doing
that like did you get any of that stuff
no and i think it's because i'm so surly
and intimidating
just because you don't give a crap
basically hello it's a little i i know
here's the thing is i
care a lot like an inordinate amount
like i
on instagram there's a way that people
can like show your stuff your posts on
their stories
if you're not aware of that and then you
can then reply with your own story
thanking them
on your story showing that they're i
used to do that to the first couple
people that would always share my stuff
but i couldn't do with all them because
there was so many i i didn't want there
to be
a constant flow of me just thanking
people showing my own stuff on my story
it'd be ridiculous but there was someone
who's like hey man
this cut people why don't you ever show
my story man i've been following you for
three years dude
do you hate me you know so i stopped
showing people's stories you know i i
really
i care that's that's gonna haunt me for
[ __ ]
yes people kind of i don't know man i
think people are kind of worried about
talking to me
why so well because like i don't i have
this tendency
if i don't agree with somebody to be a
little
abrasive wow i know that feeling
[Laughter]
wow we share that yes yes he knows that
feeling too
not like it respectfully respectfully
abrasive right it's just like even just
like either critiques or feedbacks it's
just like i'm not
i don't sugarcoat as well as some or
beat around the bush i'm just like
this is what you need to work on because
like whether i'm training people at work
or whatever it is it's like
this is what it is and i've been i've
got feedback later on like
hey they said you were talking it felt
like they were getting talked down to
him like
really not what i'm going for yeah i'm
just like i am so sorry
but like it's one of those where i'm
just like i'm trying to help i've been
doing this for three years you're brand
new
same like same thing with you as art
it's like hey this is just like some
feedback i've got and it's like and you
just feedback
it's like yeah i was like and nobody
tends to tell me feedback it might work
the same way which is
not because i'm an expert but i guess as
like i i wonder if i give off that same
prickly demeanor
what was it like grumpy
do you think what's up i'm gonna switch
over i love this piece by the way
it's not it's not because we're no
nevermind
that's not that's nice that's that's
another old piece by the way yeah i'm
psyched
yeah that's fire that was our jade
rabbit piece because the story of the
jade rabbit
like the actual mythology of the jade
dragon not just the gun
yeah it's a
long story
he's like whoa we'll go watch milan's
video
we collaborated there all of all of it's
there man
about the the style thing this is
actually this was one of our earlier
pieces dude
like you could tell like the techniques
and everything are just
so wild this looks fire man like so if
you look on like the
i don't i don't want to keep drawing my
attention but like if you look to the
right-hand side where the little tiny
water flaws are going on
like the like it's just like the grass
it's just like a line in the slash
line and slash it's very painterly
there's not much
really going on there and it's very
smooth so there's no
painting texture it's just painting kind
of techniques where you just
that looks funny when you do that on a
painting people are used to seeing
a various texture that kind of goes
along with it like if you're painting
on a canvas there's under underneath the
paint if there's not the paint
smear on the canvas you'll see the
canvas little woven threads and stuff
yeah so when you see it
smooth like this it doesn't attract
that many people that easily
feels like versus one of your most
recent ones is this
well there's a stream delay for me
yeah yep that's aramis not really aramis
i don't know what aramis looks like
hey that's your interpretation of fallen
queen i don't know what to call her
baroness i don't know
the fallen baron dudes well there were
also some baronesses in there and aramis
is one of those baronesses
absolutely she actually escaped during
that whole breakout but she was like
you guys do your older thing i got [ __ ]
to do
oh [ __ ] i don't even know that's what's
up yeah do you think she's gonna be like
a worthy opponent for what
a lot of people are expecting to be or
almost have to be like a taken king for
second level expansion especially as to
what we're coming up with with stuff
going away
do you think she's gonna fill some
pretty damn big shoes
uh absolutely not no that's not bad
okay okay so i know it's a little
strange but from what i'm seeing what
we've all
seen from back in destiny 1 it was very
you open the book there's the page
that's the villain with the mustache and
everything dude
now in destiny 2 the writing style has
changed
oh aldrin's so bad killcade he
killed k dude he's a puppet mm-hmm yeah
he was a puppy he had a string you
killed all like you were killing aldrin
that in fight they introduced a gateway
character
or a monster the meatball you had no
idea what the hell that was
like what is that and then that that's
that's then the next gateway
to riven yes which is then also the
gateway to savathun and stuff
so there's there's this huge layering
situation that's going on
and from what i've seen from the whole
reveal and stuff like that you saw
fallen using like ice
daggers which is kind of stacey you know
so you're like okay so the fallen
used to use light and then the traveler
left them in the her
in the hurricane no i never was there
anyway but it was it was there whatever
they called it the collapse for them
yeah and they followed him or her
actually i think travis was a female
quote unquote uh over here and
you know so they can wield para causal
stuff
like us right and there's also more lore
of like a
apparently like a fallen resurrecting
someone
or something recently it might have been
mythrax kind of storyline
exciting yeah so seeing as
mythrax i think could very well and very
easily
wield the light along with some other
people
um there's a good chance they can wield
the darkness like the stasis
so there's a chance in this we're going
to be
thinking seeing aramus and her fallen
were given stasis to do something
and be a nuisance to us but it's going
to lead
further into okay who gave them that
right
where did they pick that up who gave
them those keys
i feel you who is that who's the where
it's
like right now we're we're waiting to
see all these puppet masters
that have been building for what six
years so far right yeah
wow well sabbath is one we're gonna
finally see in year seven so
potentially i was like which queen which
queen
yeah dude who who else is that going to
be
i mean no i mean dave and she even says
sabathune and like the cinematic ends of
all his office she's like sabathune
projects the little thing in the wall
and stuff like that and now i gotta ask
you
always like to ask for a confirmation uh
so do you see this is my theory you
gotta tell me just a quick yeah your
name
we're getting europa getting cosmodrome
kind of fleshed out this season
so kind of new destination old revamp
next season
whatever new destination comes with
witch queen
also rebuild dreadnought
if we're getting the wish queen
dreadnought makes the most sense
oh no that's that's okay i actually
enjoyed venus
venus but they'll they'll save venus if
they're bringing venus back
it won't make as much sense as the
dreadnought with the witch queens they
probably won't
if they are bringing venus back for
whatever reason it's probably going to
come after the witch queen
with some vex name because the facts
were all about venus that's literally
where we found the vex for the first
time in d1
yeah right so if they're bringing venus
back if they're
along the same noon old pattern it'll
probably be for
vex thing so i'm gonna have to play d1
to see my venus but
or just play vaulted glass when it
launches sometime in year four
well maybe but like that's the thing i
don't think they aren't how do you think
that's gonna work
like are they just gonna be like okay so
here's invisible barriers of this
control zone you can't go out from here
but start and go forward don't go this
way like maybe
i'm wondering how they're gonna do no
okay if i had to guess how did osiris
get into the vaulted class
he teleported in through that's right
almost right
through vexy [ __ ] all right so
apparently you can get to the technical
term by the way yeah through any vexy
[ __ ] you find so they're probably going
to make a vexy [ __ ]
plate and we're going to run through it
and then they're going to be like oh
[ __ ]
what's up haven't you guys in years okay
i'm good at balance now man don't you
think about knocking me off that ledge
and then
all right all right let me just all
right how about this how about this
instead
well [ __ ] man what is that
like well and vault of glasses is going
to be [ __ ]
yo i can't wait yeah yeah it's going to
be it's going to be very interesting
with the uh the d2
mechanics implemented in these raid
they're going to have to do some things
because like you said that's a good
point
an entire raid of warlocks with chaos
reach
every boss yeah like literally
literally well oh man at y'all gonna get
that work
i know it's gonna be beautiful because
you're waiting for people to jump out to
miss the jumping puzzle for like a good
30 minutes as well though
that's gonna be me i'm gonna replay all
my warlocks flew fears
how my fellow warlocks in this podcast
feeling about that right now
easy dude i'm great with jummy puzzles
yeah you're the good one you did well
it's not that hard that's what i'm
saying you can do it on all the
characters you just do it
see fix yourself it'll continue
to see i'm being nice continue he's
starting troll y'all y'all see it
i see him people just aren't good at
jumping puzzles man mostly hunters in my
view don't encourage him titans are okay
with it and
i haven't i guess what games you grew up
on you know kind of what the pedigree
platforming is
and stuff that makes a lot of sense yeah
it's like in my opinion like
the warlock jump is for people who can
get the warlock who can get the jump
done the right the first time
hunters need correction midway through
oh slander
every time i get on a hunter i'm like
how though
i'll get used to it i know i know it's
okay so those two i'm sitting here as a
titan what are your thoughts on my jump
yeah bishop is fine okay okay i was like
honestly i live on strafe glad i'm just
like
yeah no no no titan jumps like a happy
medium yeah
you can pull it off one way the other
one i will say we have the hardest
like big drop catch because i have to
start that catch about halfway through
to slow down because i can't tell you
how many times
i've slammed my many knees and ankles
have definitely busted
on my face that's that's caught me off
guard it kills it
yeah i feel like oh hold on you got to
fall all the way down for riven and
there goes the gravity oh crap
he said i have no problem with that
upper descent
thing yeah no decent dude the descent
for uh for warlocks be easy
you just oh yes it's literally like
cruise control
yeah warlock is just like easy mode
jumps yeah
on the go down yeah for just that damn
thank god they added mentally that's
what i have to say thank you
yeah i mean that's a quality of life for
everybody i'd say exactly
i do i do miss i do enjoy that um so let
me ask you this um
one thing i said about your channel and
i really like is
your starting scream is lit like
you got the going the beats is popping
like hot act that creation but i really
enjoyed it starting soon jay
thank you i appreciate that it's
actually super easy in after effects
you got to make a layer of i'm gonna
break it down
teach brother okay okay if anyone has
after effects they've got an image maybe
the stuff in the background
who knows you could use mine if you want
to practice just find a good quality
image
and put it into after effects uh and
literally just that you don't need
anything else
for this various effects right you put
in there you make it make it put in the
composition as a layer
but then you make a new layer it's a
camera layer okay you put that on top
and then you unlock the camera ability
in
in the image layer meaning that it will
now react
to camera stuff and so just like in 3d
space
in 3d space exactly so now i can do all
this you know
yes i love it so then you just take your
image
right and you and you turn the aperture
setting onto the camera
layer and you see you know so it will
have the depth of
focus so this up close will like auto
focus
and you know like oh so but in the
background over here it's all fuzzy
right so i mean you just kind of move
the camera
that's fine that's it that's fine e i
want that with all osiris images
pre-show and we're good to go
yeah i'll get right on that oh let me
let me go ahead and get out
of things going off all my stuff and we
lit i'm telling you
that's the way to go i've dabbled in
after effects which so it's like so i
understand what he's talking about but
it's really intimidating for people who
yeah yeah just just just
that i always tell people if you go into
after effects
just look at it for like a solid 10
minutes and breathe
no judgments hold that [ __ ] down right
because
you're not gonna know what the [ __ ]
you're looking at it's like you just
walked into a pyramid and you're seeing
a hieroglyphs on the walls and you don't
know what that cat's doing man
so you're just yeah after after effects
is very very powerful depending on how
deep you go with it which is always
interesting
yeah and i always suggest to look up
tutorials oh yeah
no i've seen some just two hours yeah
just a few hours of good tutorials and
you'll know pretty much the foundation
of anything that you really want to do
and you could do almost anything you won
that thing
it's like giving you a superpower with
visuals like i make my stingers and
stuff with that like the the scene
transitions for streamers
yeah fire man yeah i really love it
fantastic job i need to make my own i
was like i've seen enough like streamer
transition i'm like
i get how that transition and stuff
moves and transparency and like the
like mask and stuff i'm like i could i
just need to sit down there and do it
and i'm always like trying to do other
stuff so i just need to spend some time
and just be like
all right i'm doing this today i mean
half the work
it's it's about an hour long process
give or take if you just want to play
around with it you don't really know
what you're doing
in the head you know ahead of time and
uh as long as you have the 2d
assets that you want so like your logo
and
some background stuff and that's it and
you have a basic idea
is i need i talk to you afterwards
anyways
i don't do
[Laughter]
at some point somewhere no like that's
kind of the thing is like
i need just like so as you said like the
background image you can use your logo
and kind of move that around but i need
something in the background to work with
i just need somebody to work on making
that and that's just like find an artist
who's like can make you one
image that you can use for that and i
could actually have an illustration
yep exactly see that commission coming
through
[Laughter]
that's another reason why i prefer to
teach people how to fish because i don't
know
himself it's like you gave me here here
you watch this i'm going to send you to
a video of after effects while i make
this thing and you go make it cool
exactly if not them then maybe it'll
teach an artist
who can then make it for them and then
they can get the commission and
and i'm busy man
i feel you you know the bread rises
together see i got the vision
exactly exactly i'd much rather everyone
kind of like get better at things
together so that we can
in turn on a personal level become
better yeah
man you're getting deep in this podcast
yeah yeah that was philosophical you see
that knowledge just dropped man
bro the earth might be round but like
the universe is so big that it doesn't
have a shape man
this guy's dropping by sounds like you
just walked out of bill of ten three so
can't wait
i haven't seen it exactly i don't think
it's out yet no i just keep seeing like
advertisements and stuff for it
so final question from me uh if you had
uh are there any two
like one or two that you're like ultra
parent of whether it was like something
you like a style that you really
mastered or
we had the same question like a style
you really mastered or
like one that you just thought nailed
the concept really well or just worked
really well with
one of like milan's videos like a couple
that you're like but just like you know
you had kind of a special place for
it was that one that one for you was
like yeah that's it right there
that's the one i don't man i don't have
one that's a problem that's why that's
why i said two or three i gave you
options so
yeah yeah um
despite whether they look like it or not
i i really like the veil piece i did
recently
okay let me pull that one up you can
talk about that i was practicing
mostly on like i was i've gotten facing
and creepy vibes and stuff down pretty
well but i was mostly practicing on
fabric texture and so like if you look
at
like her hand as she's like going weird
with her with her cloth has like
it almost looks like the skin is molding
into like various layers of fabric
that's what i was working on and the
stuff on the bottom
you know so i'm proud how that turned
out and i learned a lot about fabric and
tattered cloth
from that piece yeah that's fine bro i
can't front
yeah especially for what's coming up too
with all the pyramid ships flying in and
what's supposed to happen in the fall
and i start with the pyramids the little
seam in the background so yeah and
that's the thing everybody wonders about
the conception
of or the concept of the veil and what
are the truly the veiled statues what do
they mean and there's like the leaks
about
i don't want to go too deep into them
but of you know bigger forces with
all of that and so i like i like the way
we don't know much there's some leaked
stuff but it's like i like how you
conceptualized
of what you know we don't know what it
is but it's probably terrifying
whatever's under there no matter what it
is i like
i like that yeah honestly i was all i
did to make that with the vibe is like i
just put on like
scp videos on youtube and stuff
if you don't know what that is it's it's
like a it's a horror writing community
okay
it's gonna ask what is scp yeah
that's dude we ain't got time
[Laughter]
that's that's uh that's a podcast in
itself that's a drop in the ocean man
this
uh it's huge um but another one would
probably be what else
i do i hate the fact that fellwinder's
on this this list of mine twice
but i've only got three pieces i'm gonna
go through right next one would be the
fell winter
running through the snow kind of thing
because that's my joint yeah i like that
one like that one
yeah i like that one a lot and again
all these pieces are on the recent list
after this
after the style shift um
but yeah
when it comes in artists like i i i
don't look back
on like my previous stuff like years ago
i didn't feel like oh i'm so proud of
that
like my favorite piece is almost always
the piece i just finished
gotcha nice is it probably just because
like
you were always working on something new
with each newest one probably because
you're always
yes some other addition to your skill
set because i'm really proud of what i
learned
recently and it's like every time the
the curtain gets opened a little wider
for you you see more of the crowd you're
always like
ah you know and you're really happy at
that moment so
dope kind of the more you get into
anything it always feels like the more
there is to learn
yeah exactly yeah it's like that whole i
mean if you get into video editing
you're like oh cool i can you know cut a
couple clips together of gameplay and
i'm like
then as you do that stupid stuff you're
like hey let me work on these
transitions and match up audio and then
you're watching a movie
in a completely different way and you're
like holy crap like wait
yeah right i know i know what they did i
know one thing they did there yes i know
one thing what's the captain america
thing i understood that reference
yeah it's a huge drop in the ocean just
it's just
crazy stuff so that's one of the reasons
that emily's just so proud of my recent
stuff
nice but this one was working on a
couple things uh i actually started
practicing my tattered cloth with the
cape
and uh but mostly it was trying to color
in a very subtle way yeah my black and
white
with photoshop because i started in
procreate i did an apple product by an
apple yeah i think it's an apple
it's apple exclusive at the moment okay
program
don't don't shout out to apple please
hate me so much
wow my phone just stopped working it's
so weird
crazy
cease and desist
i was making like this was my earlier
pieces when i was practicing procreate
so i made this and it was black and
white and i didn't want to try and color
in procreate and i've tried coloring
stuff in that program a bit and then i
moved into photoshop uh because
prokaryote was built from the ground up
around brushes so it brushes really well
and you could paint and draw on its
pleasure
uh but it's not that good with photo
manipulation comes out of like colors
and values
but photoshop was built up from the
ground up back in the day
on that so that's its main thing so i
just took it into photoshop and it was
just
you know when it was done that's right
question on that piece um to the right
is that a representation of you your
avatar is that is that what we're doing
it's not about me
yeah i gave him my helmet yeah like
that's his signature that's his head
that's a good thing
there yeah but what i don't i don't
remember their name but
it was in the story the lore where
they're fighting these
frames from rasputin because they're
spewing sending them these frames and
that dude
zaps with his lightning bolt like his
lightning stuff for the first time he's
like why don't i do that
and that's what that is he's not he's
not an iron lord that anybody knows he's
just some random person in that story
but i gave him my helmet which i think
was timmer's helmet
holding the whole night's thing feeling
it digging it
like the vibe number three you got a
third
i do and the last one is the uh the siva
one
this one with uh felwinter again yes yes
that was fine too
and that one was a combin i wanna be
fast that one was just i was combining
um more illustration stuff with design
language
so that big diamond in the circle and
there's the actual the the iron lord
tree behind it
with the sieve you know blowing up and
wolves in the background very symbolic a
lot of symbolism
and a lot of like i said design language
because that's just a big diamond it's a
big shape
with with circles like like basic kid
stuff you know
just big bold shapes combined with
elements of illustration so that that
married perfectly in that
yeah so that's what i was really proud
of yeah that one's fine i'm not gonna
front just to see
the pulling the sieve out that that yeah
that one's kind of
can't front top notch and i know no
piece is the same
how long how like how long did this
piece for example take
i could tell you the exact time he knows
he's got the stamps oh he's got the book
did charlotte went into the okay he's
like hold on
the official grimoire check checking
their receipts on this one
exactly
[Laughter]
10 hours and 11 minutes wow
what's the longest you know that yeah i
know the longest longest one was when i
did for uh
destiny a and z which is the
australian destiny office okay
they had an event and that that they
hired me for a a
wall mural essentially it was big
gave my freaking pc the hernia but i can
only imagine on that scale
i had to work on a half res uh but
that one took over 30 like 36 hours
that's my
longest one i've done most of my pieces
take between four
and like 12 hours yeah from a wide range
really depends on what i'm doing
wow wow the 30 how big was the mural i
mean you said half rez you just like
is it just feet upon feet like fur it's
big it's a wall it's it's not like the
side of a building
yeah but to scale because i had to make
it to scale because
it was intended for prints when it's
intended for print you pretty much have
to work on it to scale
gotcha at 300 dpi wow
yes most for the for context people who
are watching this the screen you're
looking at
no matter what screen it is okay uh
phones tvs whatever monitors the
resolution for online stuff that gets
and downloaded and encoded to you
is 72. yeah that's it
for print it could look good at 120 but
it looks best at 300
resolution that's that's dos per inch
for dpi or ppi if it's digital
but that's that's essentially it's like
pixels per inch or dots per inch
so it's just a tighter look got you
so it's a big big big file uh lift your
game
arthur he's a destiny not only he only
like destiny that much anymore but
he's a streamer he's a buddy of mine and
he was at the destiny event
in australia because he's from australia
right and he actually
they let him have it wow on his stream
like on that side i think of his stream
uh he's got just this
wall and that huge wall he put the
banner like he has velcro on the entire
wall
and it's just it's just that mural thing
yes neil mental's asking how big was
that file
uncompressed yeah it was
that was a while ago but i think it was
somewhere along the ballpark of like
six gigs jesus for an image that's
ginormous
damn because i have videos on that
this um good to see i love learning
stuff like that the creation process
and then obviously you know i'm saying
the stuff that inspires you
all cool stuff love seeing how you work
with the law community that is
super dope and just getting bringing
this stuff to life and
the last one i want to give you props is
just your versatility i feel you're
very versatile i think it's fearless
that you don't commit yourself to just
one style you're always
trying to improve and do different
things it's dope man
level little what i'm hearing gamma if i
if i actually do
set up shop in an area and like that's
my style and i'm sticking to it
if it's ever that i i hope i
want it to be a point where i'm i could
do anything
yeah well sorry is that even a style at
that point or is it just like
you're it's just you almost at that
point yeah yeah it's like if you if
anyone i am one with my style
yeah i don't really have a set style and
i've never had a set style i've asked
this
i've wanted one right that's
weird that one's got two back to back
because i look at the there's a captain
one
uh fallen captain looks a little more
kind of like lines and drawing and then
you see what looks more of the
almost more brush strokes on the vex one
right next to it just if
those are chronological just the
differences between those are really
cool
the floating blue whale though is just
crazy that looks
that would look amazing blown up i'm
sure yes the contrasting colors
you can't you can't just stick to just
sci-fi
space aliens and guns all the time
sometimes you gotta draw clouds and
dreams and fly on whales bro
building castles in the sky kind of [ __ ]
or trees or silver wings apparently
right now so yeah it's true that's a
good one um
a lot of people like that one that's a
good one it's a really good one
yeah i'll throw it up while we chat uh
i'm sure i have it yeah i do
digging the vibes digging the vibe so
yeah um
well man we could sit there and talk
about your art for a while but we also
have a game that we play too right
sometimes
sometimes we play well i mean i would
play it if it wasn't dead
no no no no i know no that's that's the
internet
or reddit or everybody who plays games
that doesn't play this
even though everybody's like oh it's the
destiny killers like six years keep
trying
yeah no exactly doesn't seem to be going
anywhere but we do have some
stuff that is going somewhere man look
at that segway right there clutch
[Laughter]
so they said back in june obviously the
destiny content vault got introduced the
idea of stuff leaving the game
people were controversial about it kind
of things we got a lot of clarification
of stuff that's going to go through so
kind of want to break down
chunk by chunk of activities that are
leaving they basically said a general
rule of thumb though is if a destination
is going into the vault
so do its pve activities and associated
rewards
kind of a general thing to follow so if
you're wondering it's a good rule of
thumb not everything but it's pretty
close
so we know io titan mars mercury and the
leviathan are
all going away to make room for
cosmodrome's return
and europa's debut so losin
in a sense five get in two now
this is the time they said we're gonna
put the game to the size that we want
we're gonna add to add and give and take
and manage the size that they want so
this is gonna be the biggest loss but
going forward hopefully it's more of a
kind of a rotation of things in and out
so it's a manageable size for them
right strikes are first
now i want to see if you guys have any
favorites of what's leaving
if you guys are like oh it's a shame
it's leaving or
see ya we've got the pyramidion
festering core sabathune song
strange terrain will of the thousands
tree of probabilities and a garden world
those are all the strikes that are
leaving so i have seven going
i'm gonna be in sabathan's song yeah
yeah that's a classic i love that one
that was a classic that was just like
i've got that one down
oh yeah i was like i know it after three
years now it's definitely one of those
that's been there
the sad one for me is festering core
because it's so recent and a
very cool strike yeah the taking orbs
and stuff yeah
and like the uh walls the like kind of
big red walls that move and stuff
i literally spent
two days ago two nights ago i literally
spent four hours
in that in a master nightfall
because i was 10 50
and i was with two people that jumped in
with me and i'm like i don't know why
you're here but you could try it if you
want
because i was down for the death and
then the pain
they were 10 20 and 906. oh no no no
no that whole
thing was like you're just slamming your
face against the dark souls boss for
like
four hours yeah we got it done wow wow
it was the funniest thing if they if
those three can do a master nightfall
nobody's got any excuses yeah exactly
i've heard feminism before is a
nightmare on grand master though because
you can't wipe
yeah no it's it's hell literally one
the 906 guy his hobby is literally
breaking and clipping the game
so what he did is he he like he has this
weird sense where he knows
like all right he has a strange game
since because he's i guess he's doing
the whole game design thing but he was
like all right
and he jumps up on a rock and he
disappears behind it he just clips right
through it and he's like seeing as i
literally can't do anything i'm just
going to sit here so we can't wipe on
the end boss
wow absolutely it took us like an hour
and a half to get through that and
he actually some splash damage actually
did manage to touch him a little bit
oh which was enough oh yeah it's like it
wouldn't take no we reset it
once but he was like i'm gonna be a
little bird
shout out to the 906 dude i didn't even
think you could get into one at that
level down
apparently maybe if you joined but
that's surprising it would even let you
try it i started it
and then they joined me and they let
them lock their [ __ ] of course naturally
it's an iphone but
like they were like
all right why am i here
what am i doing i immediately regret my
decision
yeah but they stayed they stayed it's
crazy it's four hours
so yeah you're missing there
mars mercury titan yeah mercury because
you know the family i mean i do i do
i do i love the art style of it to be
honest you know
yeah because i remember when even though
christmas cyrus gets killed a lot
just the aesthetics it was so different
the bright
oh man i love the curse the curse of
osiris to me
was like what kept me going like one of
mine was all right
chris iris though dude the music or
music they brought in they brought in
everyone that i needed to be there man
and
the aesthetics was beautiful the sky
boxes were phenomenal
beautiful past mercury is gorgeous
yes past is like just like lush the
colors like kind of unique like
color palette that they use for like the
trees and like still kind of like
feel like you're kind of out in an open
plain but it's like it's on another
planet but it still kind of feels
somewhat homey
and then you go to like future and you
get that one few shots from the tower
out
and the one point in the story where all
the vex like light up and you're like oh
crap
it's like there's just some cool moments
in that one some cool moments yeah
i'm gonna miss it especially now the
pyramid ship's here yeah right in front
of the sun and i'm like that skybox
yeah please don't go now that you're
here that's why i never want to see you
not being here again
thanks yeah the first one on io was good
because i was like you saw the scale i
was like damn
but when it blocked out the sun i was
like damn
i'm i'm perfectly fine with aisle
leaving dude i've never liked that
mustard gas looking [ __ ] just covered
right
out of here
man it's just that's the worst color
palette dude
you're looking from an autistic
standpoint me something yeah yeah
i'm gonna tell you what i'm a mess
though i'm going to miss
asheville talking his talk and
cora slandering him man yeah
probably the best storyline in my
opinion on io that i like just
considering even this the silver wings
thing which is pretty cool
especially given that that's like oh
that's where the traveler was and that's
where savathun's planting seeds and [ __ ]
nick that's the seed can
sprout a paracausal thing which might
have been where the traveler came from
in the first place like his
that's a baby traveler [ __ ] like that
but like
it's
[Music]
sadly though on the flip side i'm like
couldn't
arms dealer could have left no honestly
the one that i want to go
is the hollowed lair i am so tired of 17
immunity phase boss man
which one is this
standpoint you could farm if you don't
kill him and kiss you know when the
waves keep coming i mean yeah there's a
lot of enemies to kill for strikes if
you get that one but if you're just
trying to melt a boss
yeah hell no dude
and it's not like hey you get a chunk
it's like you could like some bosses you
might get like a smaller window
like even um yeah knocker so you get a
small win and be like cool i got a chunk
off
and then you may have to but no it's
just like you hit this damaged number
immune doesn't matter what you do so
it's a little fun i like the waves man
that's me the waves are fun because like
if you're gonna remember
one over and over and you're trying to
farm for the mindbenders
ambition yep yeah and you're just doing
that over and over again and you're like
dude this is 23. this is 23. i've been
here 23 times
what else in my spa i could mow the lawn
man
yeah like at that point i definitely
don't want like okay just can i get a
one phase
but yeah yeah i'd see that but i don't
do that so i got my minors first
so i uh i feel for your son i didn't
farm for it either i just like anytime
it comes up i'm like oh here's a seven
page boss thing yeah i've just had it
recently it's where it's like oh he's
got you gotta hit him with arc damage to
have him like drop you in the tractor
beam
his shield is totally gone and i'm still
flying in and then he slams you i'm like
it's glitz now it it's always do that to
me
yeah so then on the other side but go
ahead
i was just gonna say like it hasn't like
always dropped the thing but like
it's it from the beginning it's done
that thing where i don't know what it is
that makes him
drop me sometimes he's just not feeling
it man
corrupted could have went for me oh god
i dread when that strike comes up
i i'm like this is going to be a long
affair like doing that with like
blueberries you ever do corrupted with
blueberries i love i love dreaming city
strikes i never want them to go ever
visually i see the artist in you i know
where you're at
right that is it's beautiful it's like
swish is the best raid in all the
destiny
oh it's spicy or content i like that
well like break it down look at that let
me hear this one i like this i i might
not i'm trying to think who is on here
that just said the exact opposite i feel
recently
the move somebody said what was it uh no
is it uh addy
addy maybe yeah patty or zoey i can't
remember which do they say king's fault
they might have got a lot of kings for a
vote but last wish recently came
up with a guest do you like king's fall
or do you hate king's fall
i like king's fall okay i like them all
i
love crown and sorrow a lot of people
don't
i do what's your favorite raid that's
that what's your favorite raid
aesthetically that's what the artist it
is
that's wish it's last week i'll give him
but here's the thing
i never want to cheese ribbon ever again
because yeah
yeah because like first off first of all
right
the story leading up to last wish fire
is just like the story leading up to the
dating king yep right
except you find out okay this is the
actual bad guy
and then when you get in there you do
your thing like that's not actually the
actual bad guy what
you know and the story was given to you
like it was it was beautiful like the
the beginning of forsaken was just like
you did all this stuff and you find out
oh wait i'm just opening the bottle
the rest of the contents just in there
and the dreaming city you get the whole
situation and you get inside the last
wish and it's
and it's hard and it's an actual raid
and it takes over 24 hours for anyone to
beat
ever you know like or not never but like
you know in the in the beginning
and it's got mechanics like mechanics
dude
talk you're talking about you looking
around and like it's beautiful
and then you finally get to a boss where
you can cheese it if you want to if you
can
and the legit fight is extraordinarily
fun and not
that complicated once you get it down
just like all the mechanics like when i
go in with the team
the vault area where the [ __ ] spins
around penumbra and timber stuff
that's my favorite room really yeah
because like you just like all right
i'll read
yeah dragon breathing fire to the left
on my right great give me the ball
what's open
doo doo doo doo and like you could take
three people who do not know that at all
and say you stay here kill anyone that
gets in here
don't let him don't let him touch my
plate
[Music]
it's great i love that room and riven
legit's fun as hell because she's
you know all right and then and usually
when you hear someone talking with this
much like
enthusiasm over over a raise because i
guess they're first rate it's not it's
definitely not
that's my favorite right now talk that
talk talk that talk
wrath was great right mechanics-wise was
[ __ ] good right story-wise
it was good it's just it wasn't as deep
yeah
i don't like happiness i like how they
didn't set up access i felt access
deserved better
like i didn't all right you know exactly
yeah but king's fall
you were fighting you were fighting orex
the whole time sure yeah
he'll wait up but that's it's it's it
was a great villain
but you know you could see him he had
the mustache and everything
but he was happy we gonna minimize oryx
though orcs was godlike when you fought
that thing like you exactly
oh exactly the sale of him in the end it
was pretty but here's here's the
difference though right
if you got destiny if you got the taken
king exactly as it was
but you put it in destiny too it'd be a
joke
you're going you upset me i'm all just
like i'm gonna let this that y'all cool
go at it right now this is fun
no i was just gonna say it's like i
think
no i would say i think for raids with
mechanics both
taking king and last wish probably have
some of the most
yeah uh i mean like because even like
the pillars when you start like
if people aren't like a well-oiled
machine and you drop one even the
starting pillars fail
yeah so like those games yeah and then
you got the war priest and then gold
i like because the mechanics some of
them like some of like here's how you do
this thing
well here's what you did and a little
more here's what you did and a little
more
and then i felt taken king was like this
room's this way okay now you got to hide
behind this rock when he does this big
giant flash and then this guy's got the
pools that drop like
almost each encounter felt unique to me
which
was but it still ended up teaching you
that what you needed to do to progress
and it was great that's what you got to
do right because like
every raids like that they got they got
that formula pretty good yeah every
encounter needs to be different
right show you a different mechanic but
it needs to be important enough and
and difficult enough for you to try it
and stuff and and at the very end
pretty much all the mechanics have a
part to play and you know what's going
on because you figured them out in the
other encounters
and the taken king i think was the first
one they actually did that really well
right right but like it's just if so so
it was so
long for no reason see that's how i feel
about it but
short either no the last wish is long
but for a [ __ ] reason
bias
um i feel you i feel you again because
this this looks these things are all
masterpieces let's just say for the most
part i mean
these raids are some of the best content
in destiny it's a shame that only a
small percentage
of the population is actually playing
them which is really sad
but uh it's funny you mentioned you know
what you said about last wish because
it is aesthetically like we said we
talked about it like
it's beautiful the way it was set up
narratively right to just transition
perfectly in
the boss was epic it was an uh a secret
thing we we've had dire skull of diamond
connor we didn't know what the hell it
was
we've been thinking about arm car for
since the beginning of day one
right and we finally got to see a dragon
yep and count is unique
i i hat listen he knows i'm a vault dude
but if anybody says last wish or take i
don't
challenge them especially last wish
because i feel
that's where raids should go you know
as far as thematically setting up the
story doing stuff and then one thing
that last wish doesn't get enough credit
for
is the post the queen's work
i mean you know when you're leaving the
whole you kill
riven and you're leaving without like i
people thought the raid was over
and you're like yo what's going on in
the cool music my my my favorite beat
drops and i'm like oh
yeah [ __ ] yo tell me that's that track
dude i [ __ ] love it uh fire that's
what that's one of my own
cardio songs oh man oh that's hilarious
there's a coffee yeah that's a good one
that's a good one
when it comes down to songs though like
like the riven song
one of my favorite d2 but an entire
destiny franchise orcs still wins
when it comes down to thematic songs
just amount the right amount of french
horns yes yes
look to the salute to the uh again
destiny does not get enough credit for
audio
they do not decide that's yeah yeah
it's just it's something so you're a
vault guy like your team vault
right um i'm gonna be honest yes he is
he better not lie to you right now he's
definitely involved
vault is always number one for me that's
great
i never challenge anyone who says
last wish or take a kick it's just
preference at that point yeah no it is
complete preference
i do i will give last wish a complete
package i feel like you got the
appetizer you got the dessert
you know what i'm saying like it's the
vault is the first one you know what i'm
saying so
you know and everything is kind of
add-on add-on you're a first one that's
the difference
it will oh he does you see what he did
some people slapped every quarter you
know with the microphone
but yeah man this is good it's a good
stuff good stuff
so on the other side we have what's
coming
into the game now we're leaves we're
losing
seven confirmed we have will of crota
coming with cosmodrome
and redacted we have one bullet point
now they also say devil's lair and
fallen saber are also coming out of the
vault in year four
at some point but with beyond light
we're losing seven potentially getting
two one strike on europa
i don't want them to be any blue points
they was like yeah and what you're
getting is what you're [ __ ] getting
if they give me one redacted bullet
point for what we're getting like raid
wise
yeah wouldn't it be the craziest [ __ ] if
they gave us three
and they steal this one i love it when
they keep secrets man i'm hoping that
redact is just like we ain't telling you
anything and there's more than one
i'm just saying do you guys think it is
just one or do you think
there's more than one strike on europa
strike there's probably more
i i i hate but but like when you think
about it
the only thing really going for europa
lore wise was clovis bray
right and other than that it was pretty
much dead which is one of the reasons
they had their entire thing there in the
first place because they they could do
their weird [ __ ]
mm-hmm and they don't have to worry all
that stuff yeah
deep stone crips they're weird [ __ ] yeah
right
so maybe one maybe one until it gets to
the done oh man
yeah and then prophecy leaving and then
coming back we know about now too
i'm thinking man i'm thinking
so there might be two there's deep stone
crypt but they might save that for the
raid
that's the they haven't said the raid at
one point was deep sound
so the strike is probably
something along the lines of fallen
stuff because it's gonna be the main
[ __ ] in that area right
yeah i think they'll have like a vex one
because that seems to be the other
aesthetics to the plant i do well here's
the
no no what did they say it wasn't hive
it was it was it was was it vex and
falling because it was always like at
least two yeah because i feel like
there's almost not a pyramidion but
they're
their architecture is in the concept art
somewhere i know their architecture's
floating around in there somewhere
yeah i'm gonna leave your art as a
background but i'm sure i've seen it
somewhere
yeah yeah i mean if it's but it is yeah
we have one bullet point potentially two
more coming back
now question over the course of you know
year four
typically in the seasons we don't get
things like strikes if it
is one on europa and we get
three re-issues of strikes
what are you how do you feel about that
no i'm fine with it
here here's a little bit of a small
nutshell version
um i'm looking at this as okay this is
essentially like a d3
vanilla because they're getting rid of
all this stuff
to make room for the new [ __ ] that's
kind of what they did with d2
except but because they had to change
everything they had to wipe everything
from d1
okay so now they don't want to do that
they never want to do that in the first
place
so when they're doing this is okay we've
we've set aside a bunch of our storage
space
um like data data storage we set aside a
bunch of that storage space
for the information that we want to
preserve
the vault right and so we can rotate it
and come
you know bring it back for various
storytelling features or player
experiences or whatever
uh but now we won't lose it now you
won't lose your stuff
we don't we we don't want it we didn't
want a destiny 2 in the first place we
wanted a destiny
right and that's what we want to do
moving forward
so we're we're going to push it back but
we've got it
right we're not dropping it right but we
need to make room for the next
level of stuff okay so i'm i'm looking
at this whole thing
as it's going to introduce a whole lot
of new stuff just like how d2 introduced
a whole lot of new stuff from d1
that's there you go but it's it was
vanilla right
so like
you're seeing kind of a soft d3 yes
yeah let's see what's going with that
logically i think
where gamma's theory actually makes a
lot of sense is from
a technical standpoint i think ideally
that's probably where they want to go
and to ease point i think for you this
is where
sun setting really helps them because
when you know
you introduce all instead of like like
gamma said using the
say hey the vault blew up you lost your
weapons
so you're probably losing it but they're
going to be useless in the high-end
activities but you're going to use this
new stuff you know saying and this way
they they kind of keep that going and it
helps them with balance i
get the vision i'll see where you at
here's the interesting point right i
want the vault to at one point
at some point be so where
you can decide what you have installed
what you have access to
i want there to have d2 and d1 stuff all
in the vault
to where okay i don't have to have this
game take up the entirety of my
console or whatever thing you got i have
so many space to allocate to this
but if if you wanted to if you had the
ability i would love it if you could
download both d1 content and d2 content
just like
great be like uh i'm gonna download
venus today but until i do it's great
out on my director map or something yeah
but it'll probably be campaign based
stuff or seasonal based stuff like okay
i'll need to download season of
arrivals to have access to this kind of
stuff
and you know kind of like how it is sort
of now where you need to have
access to forsaken in order to get this
other stuff
i would love it if you could yeah
download not necessarily just locations
but you know
the whole thing right and you can choose
whether or not you have it on your
console or not and that would that's
your
interaction with the destiny vault okay
so like they have that
but i don't think like because like they
don't want it to be the only game on
people's consoles i'm like [ __ ] call
of duty
[Laughter]
selfish yeah
you got a thought about this because i
know you kind of commented on us but do
you have an opinion about
what the fall one maybe two just the
number of strikes and stuff like that
um yeah good question like potentially
three of four
are d1 strikes selfishly look
i love strikes i i really do and part of
me
feels like i understand the reasoning
and technically
you know they have to get rid of stuff
to bring new stuff in but
you know so it's a it's a lot of loss in
the beginning you know seven down to two
like i i guess my thing is when i'm
doing the vanguard playlist
i'm just worrying about not a redundancy
of seeing the same damn
strikes over like at least when you had
the seven it was some flavor going on it
was some okay
i remember this now it's gonna be a
tough pill when you get in the remix of
three to four do
things all over again but i know they're
gonna
you know i know it's gonna be more i'm
just talking about that initial
because let's be real like we know
beyond light is gonna have the heat it's
gonna have fire we're gonna have
a new raid we're gonna have a lot of
stuff to do but we're gonna have stasis
we're gonna have stasis and that's gonna
keep us occupied our mind oh the colors
the ice
we're gonna beat it right but they're
also gonna have those those things we
still
haven't gotten taken away from us like
those those stuff we still got
absolutely and we're going to be able to
come out in different ways right
all i'm saying is is the date strikes
represent the day-to-day
grind yeah right it's like it's like
going out for a day job
there you go so this is what we're going
to be doing the majority of time once
the newness calms down
we at the end of beyond light is the
same three streaks
each season holds in when you have to do
bounties for go
matches go to your crucible and all that
stuff that is
my last point i know i'm being so the
shout out to plenty we know we love the
game and we just want more we selfish i
get i'm selfish
but at the end of the day it's like you
know coming towards the
end of the season you know strikes i
just feel like
lately strikes ain't been a priority for
them
like we don't get them like how we used
to get them
you know been a while like we we get one
or two
or with shadow keep we literally got was
festering core at the same time as
shadow keep
because we got the scarlet keep with
shadow keep but right
was festering core at the same time
maybe like a seasonal drop but either
way it's like
there's been two for the entire year
yeah
like and that's and that's been kind of
the cadence of
i mean if you think about the first year
we had d2 then we had osiris that was
two we had mars
that was two like that's four strikes
right there plus what we got in the
beginning
and then over the course of the year of
shadow keep we got two
unfortunately they were they're almost
completely systems wise
focused on um events yeah
so for example the vex invasion
down they were trying that crazy stuff
out right and a whole lot of learning
involved
yeah and like but yeah
exactly yeah yeah the issue is they
they were really excited about these new
possibilities and the fact that they
pulled them off is actually really
impressive
not just the almighty but even the
sundial yeah vex innovation and they
just
they took it they they made something it
was kind of small a little repetitive
they put in the game right let's see
what happened and it changed stuff and
it worked
everything great and they took it away
and they're like
the vault works so all of shadow key was
just a testing ground for events so they
didn't really have they didn't really
put anything in there yeah
yeah i would love to see more more
strikes but again
because i've got the perspective of like
okay this is probably d3 vanilla
right i'm kind of just prepared to just
explore the new landscape they gave us
the new new zone the new weapon types
find out the best way to
probably for a full season and i'm not
really expecting to get
a lot of stuff but hopefully hopefully
it'll be something like a
d1 vanilla was interesting and it showed
you the new playground you're in
right but it didn't really give you that
much right
but i expect because they've they've
already given us they're already going
to give us
a raid yeah at some point pretty soon
and
strikes the new stuff like that if i
because i'm looking at this like vanilla
i'm like they're spoiling me now man
they've never
done this right now i feel you i feel
good like i said it's just one of it's
just one of those things where
i know we're gonna have a lot to do
we're gonna be all wrapped up in a new
content i get when you go on camera it's
going to get a little stale i i
pretty sure will i know how we as gamers
we consume content right and
he you know you know exactly says like
once
once we get to the gamers we're gonna
have that honeymoon phase
then we're gonna have that grind phase
and then once we're right at the end of
that grind phase we're kind of done
that's where i'm worried i'm not gonna
say worried i'm just i just hope that
moving forward it kind of happens what
you say where now
season of the whatever right they add
one more or two more i i just don't want
them to get away from it because it's
really a core component of of the
day-to-day
crime you're doing your pinnacles now
you're doing the vanguard strikes and
then we're going to talk about crucible
which i have issues with
it's coming so the next obvious piece
is gambit the big giant question mark
because they said hey gambit and gamma
prime at some point they're going to
meld into
one and we finally got an answer so they
said gamma gamma prime will be merging
into a
single experience the new version of
gambit will be similar to gambit prime
which i think a lot of people tend to
at least lean that direction as a single
round face off with tweaked blockers
heavier moat drain which is interesting
and some changes to the primeval fight
we'll give more details later they also
said unlike strikes and other pve
content
the gambit playlist is like a best of so
it doesn't matter if the planet goes
away like titan or mars
those maps are still available they did
say note as we perform maintenance on
the activity gambit prime armor perks
will be deprecated
we are exploring ways to rebalance and
reintroduce some of these perks as
armor mods in the future alongside with
these changes we'll be re rotating some
maps into the dcp while retaining
popular arenas for the mode
so gambit prime armor no longer
effective like literally come beyond
light
doesn't do anything for you period just
looks cool um
do it just looks cool there you go
only one mode so only one mode of just
gambit
and the maps that are going away are the
dreaming city map
and the tangled shore map both of which
you can
fall into if that helps you guys for
reference
that's a shame man those are my
favorites are they i was actually gonna
ask i was like so what are your thoughts
on the maps leaving versus the ones
staying around what do you which ones do
you read
deep six everybody i keep saying is like
get rid of deep six that titan when they
hate
what's happening the conveyor belt one
yeah i'm indifferent with that the
conveyor belt
is interesting and i appreciate it why
do you need a big [ __ ] map man
[Laughter]
my nephew calls them floor escalators
right you're in the airport
you're just trying to [ __ ] get there
faster dude
you're looking around they're hiding in
some [ __ ] bush just just in an attic
area of a gut of one of those little
buildings like
you know then you're like all right you
get 10 seconds and i pull you back oh
damn it and then you get shot from some
[ __ ] randomness oh it's the worst
it's a big map dude shout out to the
dudes hiding from the invaders well then
the edz
on the other side is almost as new red
saying it's almost too small like it edc
is
the en you can never get away from the
invader in that one it feels like
they've always got enough time to
i know it's great you can it makes you
confront a little bit of the issue
it's it's nice to it's healthy for you
to confront your problems
if one of those problems that you need
to address on a personal level
your your unable your inability or
unwillingness to um
look at a red person in the eyes extra
armor
who's shooting you with overpowered
shields overpowered
if you have an invader set you have an
additional shield and you lock down the
bank and you have
all hacks like yeah the the
you've got a team on your side yeah they
don't know where you are
until you start popping them it varies
all i'm saying so
i was like there would be nice if there
were just little tweaks to
the invader to where it was like maybe
not constant wall hikes maybe like some
pings so you could at least like
maybe try and get a little movement to
flank him i'm supposed to be like here
he
comes bam like it's like almost too easy
to track him at a point to
even if take edz the poorest map you can
go just the main structure where the
boss always is
you have the part underneath what if you
were going to the left in the last
second you wonder to the other one it's
like and you could have
a couple seconds to throw them off if it
was like more pings as opposed to
where's he at just tracking it be really
cool it'd be like
they'd be far more fair but to to help
the
invader issue a bit they would probably
need to increase the invade time by like
30 seconds
if it's just pings maybe 10 seconds 20
seconds i mean
middle that's not the middle 15's the
middle
yeah but 20 is better no and just
personal opinion
that was pro-invading i'm not even an
invader dude hey i've actually got the
red i've actually got the red jersey
so yeah guys yeah yeah no i i will
invade if i have to but like if i'm if i
have to invade it's bottom tree dawn
blade good luck
that's the lethal one yeah get that
tracking you know
no doubt i feel that i feel that's not
impossible you could totally take me out
but like you know that's a good set it's
a good it's
it's a vorpal sniper mm-hmm yeah i was
gonna say people invade with truth and
just like oh my god throw that tracking
in the air
and then uh true xenophage is what
actually i see the most of right now
yeah one two done one two done if you if
you get heavy ammo bricks right now with
scavenger on
wipe out a whole team with eight bullets
from pretty damn far
so gambit so i'm actually gonna ask you
guys when they showed the director
previously late and just spoiler alert
we'll get to it later reckoning's gone
too so gambit prime reckoning
is it just gonna be the gambit button on
the director there's no
no gambit hub just gambit just gambit
yeah
yeah that's that's all we get what's uh
what's old drift direct
dude i [ __ ] love the drifter oh he's
had such a good like run this
this time as well people who i
i know people that hate him what i hate
him he's such a [ __ ] he's a fun
character
i know man but they're like he's such a
smug dick just look at him
hey brother that's kind of that's kind
of the point
yeah he is a smug like been through crap
he was a dirtbag yeah that's a pretty
good way to freeze it yeah and they're
like i just don't like dirt bags i'm
like that's fair but
story wise yes i i'm i'm pretty sure i
would rip up at
rip ashramur's arm off and beat him to
death with it if i
met him irl but like i love the story i
love it
story's great i love drifter man they
love
drift is amazing like again i don't know
like i remember when was it when season
of the drifter like i
literally with the quickest sided with
him story
i don't care what repercussions is going
on i am not but now what's funny is by
one of my friends who did the opposite
and he says that every time he goes in
there like drift is like oh there's the
snitch
yeah i love that like it's the little
like tell me who doesn't laugh i
remember we had tv on like who doesn't
laugh when you go to the pre was it the
recaster
and you oh you you talking to the stupid
little machine when he's right there
yeah and he's just like this thing on
hey no no no no no no no no no no
second window
everybody needs that shady friend you
just
exactly that yeah so
yeah gamble we'll just have to see i
changed the background by the way that's
what they kind of projected the director
to look like
so it is like crucibling vanguard but
i'm wondering if gambit's just like
click on that button and go
it's going to be an interesting piece
that that brings me to d1 vibes
yeah looking at that i'm like very d1
yeah
plus i love how you got the the
fireplace sitting on top of it
yeah hold
um we obviously we we predicted you know
obviously
on the hot seat teacher
just don't put on earth you might
predict some terrible
catastrophe oh god it's too funny
but yeah man i mean for me it's like i
mean we knew this consolidation was
gonna happen they've been hitting it
for a long time you know i'm glad
prime won you know what i'm saying i've
come full circle now or i used to be
gambit regular guy but
all game and prime now so i do like that
aspect interesting about the moat
drain and some changes to the prime evil
fight that's going to be interesting
sad about no new suits though i thought
i thought the introduction of the sets
was a cool direction
for gambit and being that they're not
going to really reintroduce that and
they said as mods i got to see how
that's gonna work
you know um i understand mechanically
because reckoning is no longer there
and you know you're not gonna have that
whole do one mode to get the other mode
kind of five going on i get that which i
don't mind i don't mind that but i was
hoping
greedy again i was hoping that we'd get
you know some suits and stuff like that
because i really did like
the the whole putting people into a play
style i i thought that was a cool
idea so and as far as the maps um yeah
i'm cool with that i i
hated cathedral scars for some reason
unlike gamma like
i because you couldn't hide like that
dude comes out the invader comes out
you cannot run like he's he it's on like
i literally have to just run into the
cathedral in the back area and
try to see which side he's coming from
yeah on the other side
i was going to say on the other side
i've seen people just like watch him
just
pick them off like yeah people who are
like good at defending on that map will
just shut invaders down so fast it's not
funny because
especially if they're up top and they're
dumb enough to walk forward on the
stairs they're done
and if i have xenophage oh i'll kill
them too so it's like i kind of enjoy
and just the ex the aesthetic of course
i like dreaming city as well
beautiful listen anything dreamer city
come on you already know this
is anything now kevin's grave that crap
could go
see that i love kelsey i like elder
grave
i cannot tell you how many times i have
been goomba'd and fallen in the damn
pool in the freaking poison water like
oh my god
that yeah it's something aesthetically
it's like disjointed
i mean it's not quite uh steampunk
is kind of how i described it i like
kayla's griff because there's a lot of
different places it's a jungle gym
yes it is if there is an invader and
you're not in spawn
you have so many options just run around
and they can just ring around the roads
because they can see you
they just gotta catch you yes yes
i do like hell's great i i i i know e
weed out here but i
it's something about it it's just a fun
i said jungle gym it's kind of
i was like yeah it's like for the ones
like emerald coast i feel like i've seen
it too and that's like they're getting
rid of the newest ones again and i'm
like
what are you doing to me well i mean we
know the classics work okay it's the
best office
people except titans it is it titan's
one of the newer ones isn't it
i feel like it was a later edition
tangled shore i think was around
six deep six and cathedral scars i think
were the later editions
i think deep six debut crimes or no deep
six in the new arcadia it was the titan
mars ones were the new i can't remember
it
mars were new i remember arcadia what
you call it being new
you see it needs to be six feet deep
dawg i want that thing in there
i can't believe you hated it i was like
and do you think we're not getting any
new maps
for gambit i don't think they're gonna
focus on gamble this season this next
season
i doubt it i highly doubt it okay i
think this next season they're going to
focus mostly on the story because again
not only are the resources already
stretched then but they're also dealing
with cove
they're all working from home they have
they've really from what i could see i
think they've got like workstations
on their workstations at the office in
the in bungie studio
that didn't correspond to their personal
at-home workstations
which are then connected to their server
infrastructure it's crazy
from what i've seen desktop yeah there
were there's a lot of experimentation
but there's still limitations
but so with that in mind
european aerial zone gambit i actually
support that
that would be kind of cool that'd be
huge crazy
that's i think isn't the eaz bigger than
deep six oh yeah
yeah it's a big map it's a big map yeah
okay okay okay for that one they would
probably have to have they'd have to
double the invasion time
but i love that invasions happen
it like i mean without it it's not it's
just like a boss rush like that
i will say that piece of it does have to
stay because without the invasions it's
not gambit
invasions have to keep you on your toes
now do i think sometimes
they come too frequently or even though
you've already got your primeval and i
don't have nothing somehow you can still
invade me that's crap like there are
certain like mechanics to the invaders
or timings of them sometimes but
yeah no they still have to be there when
i go in and i get an army of one yeah it
feels freaking fantastic to do it
so no i love invaders but crystal's
waiting on me to do something
so i'm going to be over there in the
corner for a second uh but i'm going to
prompt you guys to talk anyway
crucible yes so light gambit the new
crucible map playlist will be a curated
best of
um mix and will be pulled from both
destiny 1 and destiny 2's legacy
so apparently they said available pvp
maps in november 10th there are four it
says destiny i guess this is everything
in destiny 2 even though they say
destiny 1. i was like wait does destiny
yeah that we originally got from destiny
yeah the twilight gap rusted lands
exodus blue banner fall those are the
destined ones
um and they got quite a few in destiny 2
the ones leaving
for the content vault meltdown solitude
retribution
citadel emperor's respite equinox
eternity
firebase echo gamers ruin legions gult
and vostok
now in comparison of those two lists
we're losing probably a third
of the maps
is cool man we we we cuddly that's all
good
boss stop the only one i'm like yeah
that that could go i was so
happy about that i got a lot of friends
who love vostok really
but again that's the aesthetic they
loved rise of iron that's true they
loved
the lord iron lords and stuff like that
oh yeah yeah so yeah it makes sense and
that was that was the location
so ladies and gentlemen as you can see
here at the last word you know we're all
about fitness we're preaching fitness
here it is
look at the perfect form look at the
elbows hitting the knees it is
really really aesthetically pleasing to
see the exercise done to this level of
perfection
and right now with covey man you're
isolating you you got to do stuff man
you got to be
active you got to if you can't get out
you got to move around and e
is showing you that proper form that
great technique this is what we do here
man we're trying to inspire
try this the cadence is on beat every
single time
the motion is fluid stop until he's
finished and he sits up with great
posture
gets back in his gaming chair his green
screen is up and he's going to put his
head set
up into uh even breakers but that is
cardio refined ladies and gentlemen
look at that look like i have no idea
i never know what's said when this all
goes down so
i hope you all enjoyed that one anyways
crucible we're back yes
we were talking about vostok and how
it's so big and beautiful but
a lot of people don't like it i i prefer
i
i'm fine if it's gone when it comes into
a rotation kind of thing
not one of the one of the consistent
maps
i'm going to miss equinox you know
what's crazy
is that right angle map it's a triangle
yeah so it's it's it's these
it's the one side here one side here oh
for cognito
planet it's uh the knight trials of the
nine
yeah trials of the night but it was
the first trials one that that yeah it's
like this
is just it's it's you start here spawn
here spawn here
with some tunnels in between and then
you meet in the middle that's where
he is so whatever i like that map you
get with that
because on the inside like it's like
rats in the maze but the people on the
outside of the maze have snipers on
cyprus yeah yeah that was the
i was like when scout rifles reigned in
d2
in the beginning and we had the devil oh
god i hated that map
oh god i despised that man i mean yeah
i mean you know what it is too it's just
i'm such again this is the osiris fanboy
coming in
i i just was not i didn't take well to
trials of osiris
going away when d2 was introduced and it
was trials of anna and i was still like
angry like what is this this
[ __ ] yeah like who's this one chick you
know i with the sock and
and all this like i was not really
feeling it so aesthetically
but um no some people do love it some
people don't if you're a sniper
you're you're a scout guy you know i get
it so that's that oh good yes
oh i was gonna say what about like
embers or spite like
i remember that one now that's callus
that's cal that's just the callous name
doing i'm
different on that one i don't really
feel strongly
either way i always look at that map as
a countdown map
i don't i don't know i always i don't
know i don't feel
like oh man i'm going to really miss it
but i never really had to play it that
much
yeah when you it was it was big on
countdown like when when uh
charles was doing countdown or whatever
that was um you all it always would come
up
i mean it looked dramatically it always
remind me of leviathan i thought it
looked cool
um you know it just it doesn't do
anything for me so what about you
how are you feeling about i don't know
it's just i mean it always like was
kind of would throw me off as like all
gold and shiny and just like a lot of
the pvp maps are more
flat colors in the same way like deep
six the titan map they're not like
as it just was always kind of like a
refreshing oh man we got crazy gold
statues in here a little bit
like yeah the path around the outside
you have a little tunnel in the middle
you have the long so
they have their i they have their like
three lanes i feel like it's like um
what's that what type of game is dota
because i'm blanking for a second it's a
moba well
moba they have their lanes and i'm like
i feel like we have our three lanes in
every crucible map like that we have in
some way or another
and it's like i would love to see
different styles like the ones where
cauldron um or the anomaly like more of
the circular type or just different
shapes of maps are would be nice for
them to see
um dead cliffs i think you have two
right no you get three
i can't see i would have to i literally
have to like pull up a picture if you
guys like talking about a map
dead cliffs is on the european dead zone
and it's the one where you spawn
uh it's just oh yeah yeah
yeah like everybody is um like the
outside's all like the rusted buildings
b is in the building with like there's a
cracking
giant crack in the wall bees inside
there's another crack
and then um it's it's like a very skinny
triangle yep
yeah yeah fair enough any anything on
the list
um gamma that as far as like just
leaving that you like man i'm sad like
that one's going i really
like that one equinox
you love equinox break it down i'll take
you over to the dark side get me over to
the next okay
if i was equinox is only fun if uh
if you want to practice long range if
you want to practice bows snipers scouts
etc
maybe even pulses yeah you can bring a
pulse just to shut down other people
trying to bring snipers
but if you're trying to practice snipers
or something or bows
or scouts equinoxes is amazing
because just as long as you bring like a
sidearm shotgun whatever
your sword you know to handle the
tunnels
right outside you can stay up top you
can go
in go for the heavy you know whatever
you got to do and it's just a great way
to practice stuff and the palette is
is very gentle it's very light
very calm everything is well lit then
and then the
in the outside of the skybox is is space
essentially but with like a very gentle
kind of deep cloud vibe
you know and you can see the enemies
easily
yes that is true you peek it's on
don't bend i've done a lot of like
private games on that like a lot of
working on like aim and [ __ ] fair enough
enough i definitely i definitely feel
you on the uh
the sniping long distance practice that
kind of yeah that map is
completely built for that and i think
that's why because i'm terrible at that
that's another reason why i hate it but
e like what about what about you as far
as um
what's going on i'm not as closely
attached to like any specific ones like
they do seem like
as equinox and solitude i think both of
those are the nine ones
those both seem to be going mm-hmm uh
impersonal spy just aesthetically like
they're i don't know if they're trying
to make aesthetic choices or just like
fan favorite type thing kind of seems
like a little bit of both
yeah that's probably a combination of
fan favorites and the ones that give me
less trouble
yeah probably so much plenty of trouble
though
yeah i was gonna say more than the maps
though they say as year four starts
we're taking the opportunity to focus
crucible experience by reducing the
number of playlists and modes available
to play
uh they're going to increase the match
making pools hopefully make it easier to
find matches better connections
and basically they state what's going to
be around
is rumble clash control which includes
iron banner
elimination which includes trials
showdown survival and mayhem clash
i don't know if those are rotating or
what the ones that are leaving
uh into the vault and they said some
could come and go
but they said supremacy countdown
lockdown breakthrough
doubles and they say momentum control
and scorched
will return at some point during year
four okay so that one
like momentum control is fun every so
often because it's really good for
weapon quest but it's also like it
everything feels different in there so
it's like
it's quick sandbox like gnarly yeah yeah
so like the fact that that's not
completely leaving i'm happy about
um if you're starting knife grind that's
what you gotta do there you go
yeah exactly what i did yeah jade rabbit
200 time or two or however many
just uh but if mayhem clash is on the
director for good
this whole thing's fine with i'm fine
with yeah
mayhem he's making like because like if
i play like
rumble or if i want to play and clash
actually being there is a good thing too
because it's good just to not always
have the points
but every so often if you just want to
burn off steam it is the best way in
this game to just
literally may him fit so well because
it's like abilities grenades super
heavy it's like cool that was fun and
crazy nice
like it's just bonkers and i enjoy it
but i always hate that i have to wait be
like oh it's like another two months
until you get to see it again
and i hate that so it's like mayhem is
like the antithesis of a competitive
pvp's dream
it's just crazy it's just supers and
abilities mm-hmm yeah so i was like you
have that you have control you have
clash you have rumble
showdown of course the off-comp and
survival somehow with glory whatever
they're gonna do with that maybe it's
something maybe nothing
but clash mayhem being there is is the
nice one i was like if you're gonna
shorten it down you gave me my
you know burn off some steam yeah
absolutely
what about the cog so you had thoughts
was it more the maps or more the modes
uh motor maps i mean i felt like um the
modes make perfect sense consolidate it
get the playlist right get the the pulls
more engagement as opposed to everybody
split up
shout out to stadia because they they
suffer from this quite horribly
shout out to you know the 10 people in
each mode but
the whole thing is yeah this makes sense
my
happy you know i'm a trials guy just to
see the name
still there nothing changed you know
what i'm saying as far as that hopefully
we get some improvements i don't know if
it's this season e
you know i don't know if it's just the
one where they're actually going to
really deep dive with the adept weapons
and
the the sets and all that but um season
13 if they're still on that if they're
still on their plane
yeah you're right i think you're right
so yeah that that makes sense i think
you know the match was important my
focus as far as what's moving out
i am a little bit of a supremacy guy it
doesn't come up enough i always did like
supremacy right just pick up the candy
yeah it's like pick up the little you
know that's it yeah i like candy
yeah piece of candy i agree with all my
mental control i thought that was
different but everything else
i'm like you know what i didn't got much
problem with this i'm like yeah count
down and go lock down and go break
through can go
like yeah not much not much objection
here for the most part just
my whole thing is you know obviously the
maps but you know with trials i'm always
going to beat
a dead horse you don't really really
have to make
i mean at the very least they're not
going to add any new modes in the new
stuff just yet
please for the love of god the
anti-cheat uh-huh
i want them to just implement that on
the sly overnight don't tell me
again yeah like what happened to my
account
it's just coming at it with a scythe
with the high grass yeah
and i just want to see like all the
community managers watching toward and
be like i feel like i've got an issue
and they just put a smiley face
and they're just like
wow
you don't know how much you're killing
me by the way oh good right now yo i
ain't gonna friend you
it's been sitting here it's called
raising canes it's probably cold i'm
sorry
but it's i'm all heated up later but
it's it's kind of it's it's a full thing
i haven't touched it i've literally just
hold on is it a box or a neck it's a box
actually it's custom i got a box for
other people but this one's
i'm actually going to share this with
people it's just they just order the
fingers
and some bread in the sauce educate the
non-texas
folk here what is raising cane's what
honestly
literally is like a very bare bones menu
it is
like chicken tenders uh basically
amazing texas toast
usually coleslaw and uh
fries pickle fries like crinkle fries
and then their cane sauce which i
believe
is like a combination of ketchup
mayonnaise uh
what else i don't know i don't need it
i'm a picky eater that's all podcasted
itself
that is my entire condiment man
just eat the chicken dog yes chicken
plain yo i was at guardian kong with
this man and we were eating
and i was looking at him eat in
bewilderment as he's separating things
so this that'll be another podcast we do
ease eating choices
do you do you eat sushi actually no my
wife does but no i don't
why is that i don't no i actually will
eat fish if it's cooked
most fish actually i don't like i don't
like raw fish
mostly because what about what about
ah man okay next next time gcx happens
i'm gonna like try and find a place with
like a chinese buffet we're gonna eat
small little baby octopus yeah we're
gonna let them try
okay so i'll eat calamari okay it's
friday with
with tiny with tentacles and [ __ ] okay
depends on if it's
like it depends on how it's cooked yeah
so
i'll try that like i've had calamari so
i mean i'll try and the little like
tentacle pieces sometimes
but believe me my whole regular eating
habits
yes i was like even like sword fish i'm
like yeah it's fine but it's not that
great um
no there's a lot of but there's a whole
podcast of of my eating habits guys
that's
that's that's a rabbit hole i i felt
like
that god i i didn't know you i like i
learned who you were
at that vote with your food truck i
don't eat condiments on hamburgers that
should tell you
a little bit right there zero yo
grandma you see your face that's where i
was at i was like
you you exist
[Laughter]
where does this happen yeah but here's
my argument on the other side though
when i eat a hamburger i can tell you
who actually makes a damn good hamburger
who makes
who doesn't make a sandwich of crap all
over it i can tell you who makes the
best
patty like seasoned well cooked right
you know you say hashtag not by ibottas
like again if you salute this man i
don't know how he does it man
okay here's here's something okay when
it comes down to texas barbecue like
brisket and stuff
i'm totally agreeing with eubantas here
okay okay you don't need sauces you
don't need rubs
if you get the marinade right if you
cook it just right if you've got enough
you know if it's medium rare the whole
thing you've got enough blood in there
you can have a damn good like if you
prepare it and get it right
regular barbecue without sauces that
stuff is fantastic
you know there's culinary podcasts a lot
yeah a lot of other states have their
own way of doing things like some
pride themselves on dry rubs sauces and
stuff and we don't we just we just
make a damn good brisket yeah yeah wow
this is this is you learn something new
but the burger thing i just can't
[ __ ] understand
hot dogs no ketchup no busted that's
what we do no ketchup no mustard no mayo
no
i hate pickles i cannot stand pickles
that is
i can't i can understand some people are
like that i
don't i can't even stand the smell like
my wife will have them on her sandwich
across the table and i can smell them
and i don't like it
yeah but like there's so many different
types of pickles it doesn't matter it's
a pickle
no you don't like cloth smells like no
no i can just she like cucumber oh you
can't say like
no i know i know pickle is a cucumber
but typically i don't eat cucumber
either so
i've had like cucumber water so that's
more like the essence for like
kind of refreshing but no i don't eat
cucumbers what i'm gonna do
i wanna we're gonna do a podcast we're
gonna invite stonewolf who's his brother
and i want a visualization of young e at
the dinner table
oh you don't even wanna know like he had
to be the fussy kid
oh you know i was straight up i don't
want it
yup i confuse you arguing with his mouth
and stuff
oh no i did probably throw up straight
up but
no like scalloped potatoes yeah straight
up wouldn't even eat them even if my mom
cooked them wouldn't eat them
they're disgusting to me god bless your
mom for not beating you
oh no that still probably happened
something good like i would have got
destroyed rejecting all this stuff at
the table
yeah my parents tried so many times but
after i threw it up they're like okay
i'm gonna stop trying wow
yeah i would have just put a bucket next
to you i'm like if you're gonna throw it
up during the bucket i don't want to
clean it up
you're gonna eat it you gonna eat this
you just waved over it you go
eat you gonna eat this see but it's like
that's the thing it's like i will eat a
potato i don't want a cheesy
nasty slimy textured potato that's i
think what it is i think that's what it
is i think it's like there's some
texture involved with some foods
yeah i think what it is is you mentally
don't like your food manipulated or like
like you said the texture i think that
affects you and you're just like you
know what i don't have nothing to do
because it seems like it's almost
any condiment anything on top of it you
like salt
yes oh yeah that seems a little
manipulative don't you think
that's like spices and flavors is one
and like spices
no no ketchup like like what about like
peppers
what do you mean habanero chili um
so like in like actual chili or mexican
food and stuff like that yes i'm not as
much a fan of like vegetables themselves
i don't like them
raw i will eat them cooked and more red
and yellow versus greens
with this man wait why green bell
peppers their green bell peppers are too
potent i'll do a red bell pepper a
yellow bell pepper like cooked in
something and like
and i'm okay but like a green bell
pepper if it's a lot of it
green bell peppers are potent chocolate
compared to the others
she truly loves you like that is
love right dude relationships okay so
burgers i will do
caramel i will do cooked caramelized
onions but i don't want raw organs
i mean i guess it's not it's not bad
that like e is particular
you know yeah yeah
sometimes it's good to have to have
someone around who just knows what they
like
i was like i yeah i'm pretty straight
forward on my orders so
i loved it
did you see me over there there's a
reason i'm like trying to eat really
healthy right now i'm not as thin as i'd
like to be i can still eat food
clearly i'll eat anything i mean well
that's that's different like i would eat
everything in that
except the cane sauce and i don't like
coleslaw that's the other thing i
wouldn't eat in there either
it's it just broke gamma
i i bro that was me at guardian con
sitting across from we're in a
restaurant and i'm just i was just blown
away i'm like
learning all these things and i'm like
so what about this so
that doesn't work either no it's funny
it's good
uh matt came to last this last guardian
yeah right
we actually had a drunk together at a
barbie hammer and fall out yeah i know
the cat gets shocked what's up yeah so
me that was the first time me and matt
ever like met we've been working
together for like four
years straight so ever we talk to each
other
at least like three to four times a week
sometimes once a day
you know for years and we just been
doing it for so long we didn't even have
that moment of like oh my god it's gonna
finally [ __ ] talk to you and meet you
so we just immediately went into like
you wanna drink yeah
it was weird we didn't we did we didn't
get to have that awesome like come on
comradery moment we just like we've been
doing this for you i know everything
about yep yep
because it was just like it's about it
it was just like we picked it up like
exactly as we've always had it it was
strange
mm-hmm no that's no i mean it's just the
same it's always gonna be the same with
me and him it's like it's just
but i brought up said hey what's going
on i
it was like a late night we was just
bugging out and then
yeah if you're going to eat with someone
they're like yeah i don't like food
no i like food i don't like food in
certain ways
is that kosher
oh my god shout out to eva this is a fun
guest
this is hilarious learn a lot man you
learn a lot yeah
you know anyways
back to destiny how long is that that
that's one of our longer tangents for
sure sorry guys
uh trials of osiris the lighthouse will
stay
mercury's going they're keeping that
little bucket
right i'm good i'm good i kind of wonder
how they'll explain
the lore behind that type of stuff but
we'll see
yeah now here's where we're getting
so we get into raids and dungeons a
little more interesting stuff so we got
the available dungeons on november 10th
shadow throne pit of heresy prophecy has
an asterisk because
say note that the prophecy will become
temporarily unavailable for a brief
period of time
to allow our team to make necessary
technical update expect details and
dates on timing soon
they also say like raids vaults are
following the simple rule if the
contents leaving so is it
so all we're gonna have is last wish
garden of salvation and
redacted but deep stone crypt or
whatever that's gonna be
so i wanna cause i know cog and i had
talked actually about the engine before
yeah prophecy is getting a technical
update
and i'm sitting there going like we
joked that like what would be the
easiest way to kind of update their
engine that is probably get a little
antiquated
take out half the game and rebuild half
of it for the new one and then slowly
build stuff back in
and the dungeon if it's related to the
new stuff like
i'm also kind of wondering if prophecy
is going to look exactly the same being
as like
is the prophecy like hey this is the old
dungeon you can play
but it's here's the places you can't go
to anymore
like is the wasteland gonna look exactly
the same do you think is it just going
to be the exact look
or do you think that it updated if i had
to guess i bet it would be
yeah i think so and about the whole
engine thing
uh there's a little bit of a
misconception with that
let's go let's get technical when
someone's like oh
like oh can we get a destiny 3 because i
want a new engine
because this one takes so long to work
with
suffering um what's that word
it doesn't work very well okay moments
uh
yeah um the engine is constantly
changing
for those who are unaware like you all
might might already know this but like
i'm just freaking out
i'm learning so ever they're they're
constantly moving the parts and pieces
to make and adjust and edit this engine
and uh from what i've been told by
people who actually work on like
engine [ __ ] that's yeah that's what
it's like if you worked with unity for
example which is a a game engine
if because that's just an open
that's that's the engine you don't
really get the [ __ ] with it that's why
you got that's limitations
right you know you don't really have a
chance to really change it very much
right but apparently like
they're constantly just updating and
changing their engine around but
the bare bones the the foundation of it
is probably
it's it's going to stick around for like
probably the entirety
of oh yeah until probably next next gens
consoles
so not like the ps5 maybe the ps6 got
you
got you it's it's an interesting
discussion because again like i do not
claim to be a game developer
nor do i know the intricacies of it you
know again
when you look at it face value it was
always something i was curious about and
i know me and e
have this discussion and it would you
know because the simple things like you
know what for the uninforms like why
don't they just update it right and then
we
we talked about it we're just like wait
a minute you know there's probably
things
cause obviously when you look at the
buzzword engines like unreal
engine 5 that's how you know you know
they need to just switch to that and
then it wouldn't be this problem
you know because i'm armchair
development you feel like the same game
exactly and
it has to be nuances that allow them to
be adaptive to be able to pivot
with the current engine in the way in
the ways it is and then
the my thing that i had to correct my
own thinking was that
also let's be real we all kind of agree
that destiny has some of the best
gun play you know yes gaming right
i play any other fps even halo if i
replay those i'm like this is
boring is all hell borderlands came out
i'm like okay so the cursor's there and
i click
i hear i hear a gunshot and that dude
reacts i'm like
destiny you're like
you feel it you gotta really work with
it you gotta work around the recoil and
stuff but like
just a lot of these just like that's the
point it's a good point
so that that's the thing and um yeah i
mean it's probably one of those
situations like you said
which is something that they they are
able to update you know it's probably
not it's it's probably more difficult
though i would say with a live service
game right obviously
constantly you know having to do things
and you can't really take the game down
so
it's i beat the challenge i gotta be
okay though ever so often be like hey
we're gonna bring the game down for 24
hours if they need to do a big shift for
like beyond light be like
shut it down like fortnite turn their
stuff off for like two days and they
started a black hole
like people will survive for two days
without destiny yeah yeah i'd be fine
with that yeah i was like and then do
what you do
all right so fun fact um
you got teleported into a strange room
by the traveler for your safety
mm-hmm there you go uh that's it and
you get to just enjoy this room for 24
hours oh okay
and then it's like well
yeah listen i'll go it all kind of feeds
into that argument of like
you you should not i'm not i'm saying
you can't because you totally can
but you probably should not just main
destiny as your only game and you
like it a lot of people
a lot of my friends are like hardcore
destiny people as you can probably guess
right destiny is not only their their
favorite hobby but also their job
yes those people are constantly upset
that they're just
that oh they're giving us the same stuff
we did in d1 or all
there's nothing new to do oh there's
nothing new to grind no need to chase
right but like they always forget like
more than half
of the people it's game
content the way they do yeah not only
that but they don't even finish the
seasonal stuff
over half the player population do not
finish each seasonal stuff
factual like not even just to constantly
grind and like get everything right like
perfection and all that stuff
they don't even finish the story factual
i was like i'm seeing i'm ranked like
175
ish on my season rank but yeah there's
people who don't even finish the season
pass
a lot of them probably don't yeah that's
the majority and gamma's making a good
point that's
literally what i call them you know the
one percenters
have to understand like it's i don't eat
it hurts your heart sometimes
but it's it's great what are you saying
i got to put you in there you the elite
you the bourgeoisie
as i sit here and play other things on
stream oh yeah yeah
i'm like it's it's like the pvp people
or or glad or or any of those people
just
you know sean didn't really bother too
much he didn't care as much i think
about running into [ __ ] because he has a
pretty good perspective on like yeah i
i'm weird but just a lot of them
yeah i'm just just you know
man
i'm not doing this game
for her get him get him together and i'm
just like
the kittery casuals
how many people do you think do this for
a living
that's a good point so few that's a good
point like relax
like i'm one of those people like i make
a living off destiny
right you hear me [ __ ]
no but that but listen that that i give
you any credit like that
takes a responsible person a different
type of mentality to separate yourself
and understand where you are in the
scheme of things at a player base
but at the same time respect the other
girl and that's what both of you guys
do well and to ease defense you know
what i mean he plays
other games when he's got everything
he's gonna say that's exactly what you
got to do he's got it right
maybe all the other [ __ ] have fun facts
but you can't just be staring in mad at
the screen because you did everything
you consumed
it's like you know like your parents
give you the meal you scoffed it down
and you mad
like everybody else savor the bite
of your waiguu filet that you got cooked
medium rare at your steakhouse and it
cost you 150
to eat a piece of meat you're like you
better enjoy that
yeah and then when you're done that was
a great dish then you're going to go
have you know filler food in between and
do other stuff
whenever things are good you get that
150 wagyu beef you're going to put a
bunch of ketchup on it oh hell no don't
freaking ruin that steak god
yoho we got teddy in the house no i will
definitely say if anybody puts anything
on stick besides salt
pepper maybe the tightness a little bit
of butter that's all you need
we need to do another one hell no yeah
no no no
no no i i agree i yeah no a1 can
you it's great it's great but like if
you if you're making a
mistake you know you don't need if you
if i take you to a steakhouse and your
state costs eighty dollars and you ask
for eight one we are walking to the car
and i'm gonna make you pay for it
you don't like steak then that's the
problem
or you haven't had a good steak yeah
maybe that
maybe you haven't had a good steak it
wasn't that destiny show
no maybe the only steak sauce a good
steak needs is oh negative man
give me that freaking that's all i need
blood salt pepper
sean's saying like 150 to stick i was
like no my probably one of my there's a
place around here called papa's
brother's steakhouse and
i toured my wife and i actually had our
reception
and their bone-in rib eye for me is like
22-24 ounces literally they dry age it
for like 20
30 day dried your wedding i always
forget and it's just like
it is amazing the flavor the like the
crust that they get on there with the
hard sear and it's just literally salt
and pepper
you put steak you put sauce i don't even
know i hope they don't even have it in
the restaurant they probably do because
the wrong people ask for it but no like
if you get a good 60 to 80
steak you shouldn't put anything on it
is my point
no i'm gonna slap it out of your hand
remember that old commercial e this is
unrelated and it was like
um could you pass me the problem with
all fruit could you pass me
could you please tell me the jelly i'm
that dude look at that compression
back in the day i'm that guy i'm getting
the a1 where's the a1 server at thank
you sir
let's get this thing nice are you
shocked yeah exactly
do you have any great people yo shout
out to teas and teddy i want to shout
about he was in the chat earlier he said
he'll stare at the screen get mad and
like it
we were talking about the whole miss
ginger is in here she i don't know if
even if i've seen you in here before
she's like this is the weirdest podcast
it's amazing that's my girl oh there it
is oh
well that's not like my not like my
girlfriend
yeah a lovely lovely person yeah
absolutely um
yeah this is not normal we have tangents
i'll give you that we definitely get
off track sometimes but this much food
talk isn't normal
just fyi normally it is a lot of destiny
but stuff happens
telling me the grind of destiny isn't
food talk anyway
pretty much yeah you know you get the
food but on the netflix i have some food
grinded out
oh dude you are so you are so fired
yeah they don't like reading for this
one yo says save that next time you're
down here
we're gonna go to that steakhouse and
you have to promise eb you are not going
to have the a1 if i take you there
all right bam i'll do that i'll know a1
at your steak spot
but you gonna go to one on my spot and
you're going to try some condiments damn
it
catch up no no no no no you're talking
here
relish or ketchup i don't like pickles
and i don't have ketchup and i don't
want it
there's a lot of people who can make
their own condiments but i'm willing to
be flexible see the difference
no there's a difference of like
no you're eating you're you're eating a
steak wrong
wrong wrong okay and you're eating it
correctly without putting stuff on okay
a god state correctly yes or just to
finalize this whole kind of
situation right i like there's a lot of
people who make their own condiments
right and for them a steak requires
various ingredients
such as a good way to make the steak in
their
opinion is with this weird homemade sour
cream or something
well see you see now okay
hold on like sour cream in and of itself
i don't like
but you can literally put sour cream in
a cake and like it'll make it like
fluffy and kind of light
so that's different but it was like
there's no reason sour cream should be
near a steak
do what have you ever tried it no i
wouldn't want
sour cream sitting on a steak i'm asking
you take a dollop of the sour cream
whoa no spread it on a steak
give it a shot no i'll
but i don't like sour cream different
flavor it's still i'm gonna taste the
sour cream and that's gonna ruin the
steak
what if it's a bad steak already well
then that's the sex problem
exactly everything you put some sour
cream on it i'm going to not like either
of them
but you guys it's a bad steak with sour
cream that i don't like that's two
strikes no
[Laughter]
sometimes beautiful polished turrets are
beautiful
maybe the eye of the beholder but this
eye says no
it would be your tongue that probably
says no yeah and then my stomach
thereafter when i throw up from eating
the turd but that's fine no outstanding
on fire he said i bet he's the type that
like his cereal without milk i'm
done screw all of y'all i'm not that bad
if i'm gonna get a1 abuse i'm glad
you're getting confident
oh this should not be great now if
you're gonna eat a well-done
sirloin that's like shoe leather anyway
yeah put whatever the crap you want on
it because that's not a good steak but a
damn good steak
should be i will never put sour cream on
a wagyu beef all right
it makes you feel better thank you yeah
i was like
if you need to cover a piece of like
cheap meat from the store and you're
like i need a way to get this thing down
because i'm gonna like probably overcook
it anyway
do what you gotta do but i'm saying i
rarely put sour cream on anything
but i'm just saying i've tried it and
it's not bad
you're just trying to mess with me now
we'll get through the swab anyway at
some point we'll get through this one
back to you uh this man said he was in
for the long haul and he committed so
can't argue that
the episode yeah be like it's like
what's the title of the what's the title
of this podcast
food food the way ibontas eats food
wrong and the fact that
ebontus doesn't like food and incognito
ruins steaks that's the name of the
podcast right there yeah
nailed it perfect feet gamma trap by the
way gotta have you okay i'm sorry
yeah don't worry just this guess that we
have on no big deal
he's the one in here with the fried
chicken that i want to eat no this is me
on like
meal prepping right now it makes two of
us
[Laughter]
i'm bro at the stairs the whole time hey
when i go through this
take eat some bites man you are good i'm
going to talk about the exotic quest for
a little bit you got i got a lot to go
through
do you think man all right so we got
exotic quests
as the content enters the dcv some
exotic quests
obviously won't be able to be touched
either progress activities or things
that you can't do
if you want to acquire these exotics via
their original quests
do these bri prior to the end of season
revivals sturm
mida multi-tool rat king
legend of accuracy sleeper simulant
polaris lance
world line zero ace of spades last word
leymon arc yotan izunagi's burden
thorned lumina truth bad juju and
i would like to point out that
statistically
uh more than half of the player
population are missing at least half
of those probably because they don't
raid for some of them
exactly yeah or the end game content
anyway yeah i'm gonna miss forges though
and that's a weird one on my part i know
i'm weird
no you're my brother's probably gonna
miss those two actually uh when he
listens this later he'll probably
go to the forge raise his hand um none
of these legacy
exotics are being retired from destiny
their original acquisition journeys are
simply entering the dcv alongside their
supported destination
but we want new and existing players to
be able to earn the legacy exotics so
starting in year 4 any exotic tied to a
quest that has been vaulted like those
listed above
will now become available through a new
memorial kiosk
situated among the vault kiosks in the
tower we'll have more information later
this season how the exotic archive works
on ways you're going to earn the exotics
you don't have your hands on before year
four but people like hey
what about exotics hold on we got
exotics
the ones that you available catalysts
that are gonna be there there's a big
list
but the what the catalysts that you will
not be able to earn
what season 12 starts are as follows so
if you want these
make note and get them now bad
bad juju tribute hall huckleberry i
can't quite
remember why izanagi's burden menagerie
legend of accurious leviathan polaris
lance i think also leviathan
war mine yep uh sky burner's oath that i
think the catalyst is in
one of the three raids sleeper catalyst
did you get yours
no i gotta get it man this hurts i was
hoping celesto
outbreak perfected whisper of the worm
and world line zero now they do have a
nice little asterisk
um where do they say
whisper we're unperfected yeah
there's certain activities oh yeah the
perfected one
yeah so they get to that a little later
it's like what activities are going away
so whispers we knew was going with io
but
as the old tower is part of the red war
campaign
outbreak perfected is out of there too
so zero hours gone
and what was your whole argument well
the whole whisper of the worm thing
whisper the worms not there anymore or
the whisper mission isn't there anymore
so now they can't experience the way to
get whisper anyway
so now are you trying to are you trying
to promote uh i'm asking about sun
setting
if you if you remove the mission quote
that again sir i'm just asking
as it's happening what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts about it
evil narrative once again sir yes of
course i am of course okay i guess
that's just going and i see the smile on
your face no i'm asking as
believe me it's like my whisper video is
truly like done
there's nobody gonna look that thing
ever again after season two when season
12 starts probably
um that's leaving and also
now they're getting rid of potentially
either the farm because
of zero or at least not the farm but
zero because the old tower
right um lots of the the two secret
missions are both going
right hopefully they'll give us more
ones we don't know yet but
i'm i made this prediction a little
while ago about how
everyone's favorite line in the entire
game you just never quit do you
take out call pick up a traveler yes
it's gonna have to go
yeah that's gonna happen or new people
will have no idea what it means
and i want to make it made a little
prediction and people were like
that's right yeah who says that
yeah oh yeah yeah that's the red war
campaign yeah that's the main d2
campaign
yeah that's literally it and that's what
the whole thing they were like surprised
like
even though they said that it's not
gonna it's gonna it's gonna change
they just were like wait whoa
wait hang on yeah that's like d2
link that's what you do you know
it's a good point it just makes him face
the reality of it all that
that leads more into like the soft d3
because it is
the the hist a lot like if you think
we're getting year three
and we're getting the the forsaken
expansion
and nothing else no seasons on either
side of that and you get forsaken
period no seasons in year three
everything else in those first two years
is basically gone
because we're losing menagerie forges
which you just said
reckoning is going so that's the three
seasons then you've got all of year one
between
war mind osiris red war all those are
gone and the planets that they can get
rid of too
like there's a lot going oh we're making
a lot of room
oh yeah it makes you feel like wow
when's the last time we had this much
room
vanilla d1 d2
soft vanilla yeah it is a strong reboot
of of sorts um i had a comment an
observation with a could give it's
watching one of your streams
and i thought what was quite hilarious
was um
being that i believe it was sundial you
didn't play as much
and i thought it was quite humorous that
you know
obviously the whole community had went
through that whole thing with the with
the maze
you just went right up to good old rahul
and just i was like
yeah right and i'm just all the story
i was like wow we're unlocked for this
bit and i'm sitting there and i'm
thinking to myself because he knows how
like i'm very disgusted with the
type these type of [ __ ] go that's why
he's he's definitely pulling a knife
right now
but all he twisted tonight but it's
funny because literally
these are situations that's going to
happen there's going to be people who
never done zero hour never done whisper
in some way they're going to probably
introduce these things
back into the game whether it be yeah i
was worried about the kiosk thing yeah
you don't say which we're going to talk
about and all that stuff it's just gonna
be quite funny that person has
no experience and for the people who
bled
sacrifice their lives for you to have
this right
and here you go walking up to the kiosk
[Laughter]
the casual i am literally i thought
about
you with bastion and i was like yo he
didn't even go through that he just
literally just walked up and picks up
bastion
and i there's a part of me like i said
we're not gonna make this debate sugar
you know i'll go on too long
we're not trying to do that but that
kills me
inside that that destroys my soul
that a person just literally goes up
like it's walmart and adds that to the
conveyor belt and moves on like that
right there but i'm
done my rant's over i just had to say i
i too actually hate it
but
i'm coming from like okay world of
warcraft is probably the best mmo
that popularized the entire genre facts
all right there were there were some
mmos that came before it
and there's plenty of mmos that came
after it but the reigning king
supreme the supreme ruler of mmos is
world of warcraft
and it's it and there might even be
emotes that do better than at the
current moment but like you know
when you want to think of a great mmo
that has done a lot of experimentation
that has thought about all kinds of
stuff see where it came from some people
have favorite iterations okay i like the
classic version
i liked bc i liked the race expansions
they have okay the only way to get this
gear is you have to go do this thing
which requires you to spend six hours on
this giant quest line and to get into
the dungeon or the raid for it
and then you've got to beat it with this
particular [ __ ]
if you don't do these things you do not
get this stuff at
all ever end of story no one can try it
you can't buy it
i like that me too i love it i love that
i want if if they gonna do that
these dudes don't get that ever
okay with sunsetting exotics no i'm not
getting out of here that's all [ __ ] off
burn them alive
i don't want them let them be old no you
just said if you can't earn it the right
way then i don't want them to have it
then how can you say you're
you don't want it sunset right i'm just
confident i want an opportunity for
better crazy exotics that's personal
personally personally
you were doing so well today you was
like you're almost my favorite guest
it only makes sense okay
i'm not going to go on the crazy tangent
i guess this dude is or i don't know if
he's above me or he's like over there on
the
no he's actually where is he uh
[ __ ] that's what you get yeah
yeah sorry i hung up every so like once
a podcast i get my little glitch so it's
funny
okay oh this is the stream's so good
yeah it's good
okay so he's to your left by the way
okay
i'm not going to go into crazy tangent
like e about maybe the
i i don't have you made a video about
this i assume you have i actually
haven't done one about sun setting we
have had like
like basically knockout knock down drag
out fights on here
actually okay on the podcast so yeah
once you iron out your
your thoughts on it into a good solid
cohesive thing use what you're gonna say
sure if you want but like with me i
love you only can do these things
if you do these things you only get this
prestige level armor with this cool glow
you only get this cool exotic you only
get all you know whatever
you only get you only get thunder fury
if you beat this raid boss with a point
two percent drop of this
and a 0.01 drop of this and combine them
in this hard-ass spot to get to
and you've got the best weapon in the
game bam right
but it requires the rate to be in the
game
[Laughter]
it requires you to be able to do those
things if it's not in the game i still
won't be able to have them
so the kiosk is kind of the only thing
that makes sense mm-hmm
and you got that one guy like with the
hat on
like a big old beard missing a leg back
of my day
that you just so willingly think is just
nothing you know it's like the old vet
talk i've seen some things man
but that's kind of the idea is like when
something goes into the vault
this is the list of stuff that goes with
it when a destination goes
story missions cinematics strikes raids
dungeons adventures secret missions
vendors
bounties destination specific patrols
collectibles
uh like destination specific activities
like the forge which
i think i basically forgot about and
then escalation protocol
and then just this destination itself as
well just
patrols like the whole thing and just
anything associated with it
and i think some people are finally
getting a realization of what that
actually encompassed and i was just like
yeah i was going whisper's going all
that stuff fine
i think we finally think people finally
are reading in the list and they're like
oh
crap like they're not ready for it
mm-hmm
i don't think they're already done dude
okay
as much as i want people to have a great
time i cannot wait for the screaming to
start
dude i can't wait
not to burn i want i want the world to
stay alive and all that stuff but like
if they every time they do some crazy
ass [ __ ]
and i think it's gonna be good healthy
overall for the
the over entirety of the game right i
know it's gonna be kind of
you know but i'm not gonna scream about
it but the best part is i know a lot of
people do
so you're enjoying their pain
dude i want to hear there to be a cry in
all of egypt as to have never
been or ever will be again i'm saying
some [ __ ]
i want to i wouldn't like yeah i
wouldn't you know dude set read it on
fire
this man is the lord of chaos that's
your new [ __ ]
the lord of chaos listen man i i i hear
y'all
i mean this is not a surprise i mean i i
knew obviously with the destinations
going and things tied
they've already it hinted what was going
on i just don't like ease enjoyment
that's
all i just don't like his joy reading
these news he's so happy
so excited to get to this point and
emphasize certain lines yeah yeah well
the whole joke was before that i was
like
hey what if they like ever you know take
some stuff out of the game and it was
literally the next week luke smith
talked about the ton settings and he was
just like oh
i was like i called it by about five
days so he still just hates that i was
like that close
it's luke stop listening to him please
thank you
shout out to what's that i want that i
want the enemy sheet overnight
oh facts give me that oh dude that would
be amazing just be like
don't say nothing don't say [ __ ] no
twabs leading up
nothing not even hey we're thinking
about work don't don't talk about it
don't just be on light launches
and people they're just like
yep i just want somebody's like excel
spreadsheet to start just getting
populated with people who are there are
you banned
how did that happen it's so weird and
it's gonna be friends
you're gonna have friends like what a
council band
today yeah he said today
a lot of other people sometimes we've
been today
look at that like eventually they don't
know what happened
it's funny but yeah i mean the only
thing i could say by last point i'll
finish this one
along with this but um you know
inevitable you know obviously with the
destinations going obviously it's gonna
make me now push to get this stuff
you know as far as um you know they're
really not given any option as to
when it's possibly coming back or if at
all um
i guess like to your point then it's
like uh gamma which is
if they gonna do this which i despise to
my soul
did it gotta be a situation to me where
it's like
it still exists but that new group can't
get it because i i get in the kiosk i
just think about d1 that damn kiosk
that's why i guess it just
takes me back there but you know that
that kind of bothers me really
but if they're going to do that you know
it should be a situation where you feel
that that person feels proud that they
have it
the new guy in the guardian the towel
comes like yo where did you get that
like yo
back and such and such you know i was
there i did this and this i had to do it
and then you just stare at it how about
what if they made a specific ornament
that you could only get
access to if you got it legit
and it looks badass so you put on that
whisper ornament
and everyone all the kiosk whisperers
are like
what how'd you get that you're like you
better be on april
dude i was being shot at by taking bro i
feel you but i need you know if they're
gonna do it
if that's gonna be the compromise then
which i like
i need gamma trap levels of art i want
flames
i want things popping out of this thing
i want chroma
i want all type of stuff i want you to
know you don't have this
i got this and y'all make you feel small
for not doing it comes over here like
i want like a sash across my chest like
a baby queen i want the gun to be like
17 different colors
and and i want the title to say whisper
just because i got that
fast yeah that's right i want the bells
and whistles i want to decide
the taken whisperer just because i beat
that and got the catalyst
because i watched a lovely ibantis video
and i know exactly what you do
yes yes yes i want the i want the new
kiosk
whisperer of the worm i want that to
look like a giant tube
like you just unrolled a bunch of
wrapping paper and it's a cardboard
piece of [ __ ]
i want my warlock looking like like how
you have felt winter like without break
primer i want deceiver coming out my
neck
i want all that i want that's how i want
to look so you will feel awake
you like damn i should have been playing
this game on that a lot of people were
like oh man d1 armors are just so much
better
oh spicy let me just let me just let me
just say something here
like a lot of people say that like do
you want armor
they were like a d1 armor is the best
armor in all of destiny
they were saying that and people do say
that and that's pretty true and here's
steel
what's up they expected they didn't know
what the hell to do with d1
right so they they very quickly pulled
out all the stops and like okay
what do you like i want to make a badass
knight with armor
okay well let's let's implement the hive
[ __ ] and make a really cool
you know monster thing they were crazy
with d1
right d2 they immediately knew that they
were for a long long road for d2 because
that was the new specs
that was the new stuff and they wanted
to eventually try and make it so they
could connect the next iterations of
destiny they didn't plan
on d2 lasting forever but they hoped d2
would
but at the meantime like did you see d2
year one
sweatpants sweatpants is an armor set
for hunters i think with like like with
combat or
hiking boots that were like folded out
and
like not not laced up properly all the
shaders were gray
every single one washed out and shitty
washed out and terrible
yeah that's because they want you to
constantly be able to grind
upwards towards something if they start
the game looking like
[ __ ] right like if they start yeah
better way of saying this if they start
the game with d d2r
dtf d2 armor your one vanilla if they
give it d1 level armor near the end of
him
what the [ __ ] you gonna do right once
you get to
d d2 year three year four
and you you brought the god [ __ ] out in
the beginning you're like
yeah then it's like i get what you're
going bar the bar is too high but i was
like i feel like the bar right now is
like the ceiling is too low that they
don't make
they don't let as much stuff shine as i
think it could
like raise so much good [ __ ] right now
well like okay for example
something for like pit of heresies like
one i fall back on
i would love that not dream bane armor
like i don't want to look like a
spacesuit
i want to look like zolmak right like
that armor would be cool like certain
things could have very specific ties
and be like hey this i'm walking around
it's like a hive night okay now we're
going into europa but hey this dungeon
has some pretty cool looking armor
and you could do if honestly like if the
prophecy armor or the daito
kind of has its theme but if the
prophecy armor was like almost more
geometrical like almost just like shapes
and very
very weird looking i would actually kind
of be okay with that because it fits the
theme of where it came from
longer is better when you finish the
taking can you
look like oryx when you finished these
rays you looked you you
grabbed the aesthetic of what you
thought and that's what made it
better and we're going to leave that
because it was good d1 armor was
fantastic they did everything wrong with
d1 but they had a very smaller timeline
yeah and they're just trying to find a
way to make sure that this timeline
stretches so
honestly like i've been doing this
fashion show thing recently right
and uh i've seen
some weird [ __ ] and i have seen some
amazing [ __ ] yeah i've seen some great
[ __ ] in d1
yes like there was some great [ __ ] in d1
yeah absolutely
but there is such a ability for people
to go
crazy like crazy in d2
i've seen cr like i would say stuff
that's at least
on par if not better armor-wise than d
didn't d1 stuff wow and and i know ebola
just humane titan right so
i have this theory because i've seen now
thousands of titans
right i've seen pretty much every i say
that i'm always surprised
but the titans have three looks and
that's it
right you might be able to combine them
if you're clever but it's just
you're either a a knight a trash can
clown
machine machine that's it that's it
like every set is either a knight a
trash can clown or a murder machine
you combine them like you can get a
nightly murder machine or a trash can
clown murder machine which is
terrifying that's like insane clown
posse but you know
yeah some people love it
listen i will give you the fact that you
know i guess with shaders and
you know the the there are a lot
the the volume i feel volume there are
so
what i'm talking about and i think what
he's alluding to is more
aesthetic per activity and
and just the feeling of um
accomplishment when you do
pinnacle activities especially you know
these are things
like amazing yeah you know i'm saying
like one thing d1 did so right like
you did a lot of these you know strikes
well even when it comes down to the
sparrows and the ships right
you know you know what i'm saying
remember i want that michael bay when i
drive into an area
you know man like i just missed certain
things and it's just like
again they're trying to get better but
that you know it just
immediately and d2 went to the ever
verse it literally led to every verse
and you're like yo this would have been
a cool thing to earn in game like
why don't we do that anymore
that i fly around with all the time
should have come from bit of heresy
like that type of and that and granted
they took one of the ever
south sets out and put it into prophecy
as a small like
they're trying but i was like again that
stuff needs to happen much more
frequently
and at least in equal levels of like hey
if you go do this really hard thing
and again set them apart this really
hard thing you solo flawless it
cool here's this thing or you can go buy
it
like you could do it both ways but make
one
option be earnable maybe make it a pain
in the butt though yeah
at this point i'm as we'll say pain in
the ass because i'm definitely marking
this thing mature
i was asking
zero hour kills me because you know when
you do it with all the extras
oh the trash can ship why is that ship
so trash oh you could have a see the
ship that would be so cool in there
exactly why that trip it is the worst
i'm like
who whose decision was
that's like that's like a bungee guy
troll and be like oh you do this crazy
stuff look at this ship
yeah look at their expressions on their
faces it's so ugly
i'm friends with a lot of artists but i
don't think any of them do any ship
stuff
but man they've got some weird choices
with those ships dude some sparrows even
a lot of spares are great
i mean some of these ships are like
they're really experimenting like one
looks like a [ __ ] walkman cd player
a sparrow literally looks ribbed for her
pleasure and i'm saying
wow last
word after hours
they've got a lot of creative freedom
that's great yeah
no doubt some people love it like you
gotta have meme loadouts i mean i
suppose
it can't be bad like you know i i think
ninji was one of the ones who constantly
just rode around in that freaking dildo
copter
wow you just plow right into people it's
like i guess they couldn't take it
there goes these sponsors
go ahead and cancel that appointment
you're good nice knowing you guys okay
you're good you're good
last thing is um as long as i i gotta
get these damn catalysts y'all i gotta
get my cat yeah
now i will say this is the blessing in
disguise for the delay
people like all this stuff's going away
guess what you got 83
you got two and a half months november
man you got time
do it it's not it probably most people
probably have at least half of this
stuff
and it's not impossible for even a
casual to finish this other half
by my favorite weapon and it just i just
hate that the catalyst is so
rng there's not a specific path like you
just
gotta keep running it and just hope that
it drops to the chest and you know kind
of thing so what's your weapon
oh super similar it's one of my
favorites oh i got you yeah
i'm a big sleeper guy big dude i gotta
get the freaking bad juju catalyst
that's one of my d1 favorites oh yeah
that's true
tributary i need one tribute to do that
and i just haven't sat down it's just
like
i need to go get a few pieces of armor
and then just like go play some crucible
and be done and i just need to do it
that's that's one that i'm like you're
busy playing i don't know whatever
you don't feel bad that game is amazing
dude i know
i i haven't played it i don't have it
but i watch it every chance i get and
i'm like what
every time it's something different for
you as like you would
have lost in photo mode wouldn't you
just like no i don't like photo mode and
game no
it's i will say for me it's not that i
sh i shouldn't say that i don't like it
i never give myself time to use it
because i'm always trying to play the
game because i never have time to do
anything
like i will say
yeah the environment is a character
i love that that's so good i've never
played a game
where every time i go to a different
locale
i'm in awe of what i'm seeing oh so
you've never played like the from
software games
yeah but i don't i don't consider it
like tsushima is
is something different bro it's a
different vibe for sure
yeah it's just different bro you got to
play it on lethal
i will tell you that don't don't don't
kill yourself
you don't have to i will say but i will
say for like
i feel like a badass hammer it's like
i'm this guy's that ching
i'm like if i slash somebody like
running at them completely across the
chest with a samurai sword
they're gonna die and they do and i love
that aspect of lethal mode because also
if i screw up trust me i'd die real fast
too
but when you go on a tear of like six
seven guys and just go completely ham
realism i know where you going yeah i'm
so good
yeah it's like it's not for everybody i
get it but lethal mode like
if you can build up to it ah man feels
good
yeah crystal's bad you're not calling it
a katana he's
hannah i'm sorry what the samurai sword
yeah he gets a bag
crystal's very crystal like can tell me
like the name of every weapon that
anybody in the game is using be it the
enemy
anybody else the size of the longbow
that should be taller than me like
the dude knows his weapons no question
about it so yeah it's a katana i'm sorry
katana but anyway what else we got eve
there's a twap in there yeah there's
there's a little bit of a twelve we are
almost there
guys we are almost there this journey is
about to finish and this man can finally
eat his damn cold ass dinner
uh i'm gonna heat it back up yeah i was
like there's a microwave in your future
or an oven i don't know
toaster oven might be a nice balance
make sure those fries are crispy
i got [ __ ] i got i got stuff to do man i
started a piece for
the next mile and piece last night and i
haven't gotten touched yet since then
and i've got to finish it by
saturday like i get two maybe three days
sometimes to do these pieces each
well we appreciate stealing this much of
your time so last piece
um the year one campaign so they said
with some of the core year one
destinations entering the vault
it's true free for all players red war
cruisers war mine they're not coming the
campaigns are gone
they said they are building a new
expanded guardian origin story
on the cosmodrome that will launch us
alongside year four and will be
available to all guardians to play
i'm excited for that it is designed to
introduce you to the world and mechanics
of destiny and prepare you to play the
action memo we all enjoy
just feels like a cliche line in there
you could have just said mechanics of
destiny period but that's me as
editing i enjoy it the forsaken
and shadow keep story campaigns will
still be playable and i think this is
them
tying almost a stranger in d1 and kind
of getting rid of all that stuff in the
middle like
forsaken's there but it's like forsaken
savathune that ties into like
the witch queen in like year five or
whatever that's gonna be right now
they're somehow gonna connect like
year one of destiny 1 to europa
and like kind of take a big giant eraser
in the middle
well i'm guessing not much of
your dude wait hang on oh
what oh thinking light bulb
what's going off yeah if they were going
to try and connect the stranger because
that'd make the most economic sense
yeah yeah you'd have to go from earth to
the moon
but you'd have to go to venus
it'll be some abbreviated version but
it's like version probably
yeah can you imagine seeing this what if
she hands you the stranger's rifle
as new players get the stranger's rifle
axe they could flip it
they could flip it bro little power
that's how you finish the cosmo journey
you get to the tower here's this i'll
see you
when you get out there or whatever see
you on the ice
see on the ice grab your skates
but like i wanna that'd be gonna be
interesting i would love to see
d1 moon stuff on the d2 moon
that'd be cool yeah i can't [ __ ] wait
for cosmo d2
i'm about to oh my god like i could only
do it right now in that one little small
section
where you go do the that thunderlord
mission
yeah like give me the rest
cosmodrome is going to be smaller for
season 12 and i think they said they're
going to flush it out in season 13. so
you guys hope they do
yeah it's like season 13 it probably
will be everything but plaguelands i
would guess
dude they're going to put dust light
where the sport and spinfoil used to be
remember
they're they're not going to have spin
foils they better not be a
14th currency yeah 50th
ah man get i think they should just get
rid of all the currencies oh man
except like the basic materials on each
place
and a couple of the things that you have
to farm in various hardship like like
maybe enhancement cores or the upgrade
modules just pick one maybe or the
shards
but like i want to be able to take these
things and actually
make different [ __ ] with them because
right now they're only used for like
what just random infusion numbers right
basically
yeah there's not much wouldn't it be
cool
if there was maybe like one or two sets
or various ornaments even
that you need this much [ __ ] to make
right you know what you know i get where
you're going but that's a quality
a life thing that leads into the whole
making it more mmo like
right so that would not be something
that they have the resources for at the
time yeah
absolutely drafting would be like your
five true crafting yeah that would be
for e i mean your guy has like a zillion
mats all day
six thousand no i'm not running out i
got like thousands of each one
still i'm yeah i'm tired of having them
but also that's a question like i even
saw glad tweeted and i think half of us
thought of it who read this thing it's
like
so we're losing four destinations plus
leviathan it's like what's happening to
all the currencies from those
destinations do i need to go
turn them into spider for shards just so
i take those with me are they going to
be needed later
what do you feel depreciate stuff or
some type of trade-in to some vendor
to give you they usually always do that
it like most extensions but
yeah it's like that's just one of those
things again at some point at some point
i feel like we have to resolve the
dreaming city
loop from hell yeah when that happens
what if that happens only in the witch
queen i'm way i have to assume it does
and i pray it does because if it doesn't
i'm gonna be pissed
yeah what if they make it from like to
resolve it you have to go
into the curse and the curse is used as
an antenna to like
you have to get to the dreadnought so
you go through like an ascendant portal
to get onto the dreadnought from the
dreaming city
and then you've got a i'm just thinking
some weird storyline-based stuff
yeah no like yeah the witch queen
dreadnought and dreaming city
have to be tied together otherwise
they're i feel really sorry for the
awoken at that point
because they're just over there going
like well this sucks just
suffering pedro's over there like man
what years
god damn it's the same thing
[Laughter]
like groundhog day all over again that's
funny
that was just saying you made a murder
battery it's very interesting
yeah yeah that's actually like i think
that's actually what they call it
a murder battery really yeah that's her
that's her term for it
i mean she had to be clever she has to
be clever her more clever than her worm
and her worm is pretty clever at this
point and she has to constantly up the
annie
so what she was like i need more tribute
to feed this [ __ ] thing
the worm and so she's like how do i make
more tribute
that the constant state of death and
then curse and stuff that'll do it
and so that's what that that whole
jeremy city situation is just
what she calls a murder battery to feed
her to help feed her worm
i'd always heard that at some point and
then i can't remember
if that was like savithoon like
basically everything from sabbath i feel
like you can take with a grain of salt
as well because she is
kind of a trickster to a point i've
heard that at least
i i'm curious to see if sabathune is on
par with
the pyramid ship people cause i don't
think the pyramid ship people are the
darkness
well i don't even know if we're gonna
see him no i don't think we're gonna see
him for a while but yeah
lightfall more type i'm curious to see
if like they might be allied
right it might not be right because it
doesn't seem like they're allied at the
moment
[Music]
you know i would love to be like i would
love to talk to a right
all i can say is there's a lot of
dangling threads of stories right now
hanging out there unfinished
before this whole thing wraps up however
long it takes
i want like a few of these major things
i want to see the end of them
before the game just like runs out of
like money or gas or just like
development commitment
like at some point if it doesn't get
there please let the writers like
release a book
yeah i will sit there and read just one
way or another there's too many stories
that i will like
because i don't know if they can't get
through all the ones they've set up or
if they do
gonna be insane but i hope so we'll see
i talked to some of the writers
uh i never talked to him about future
[ __ ] because like
but i'll have to ask them i'm like hey
have you all considered maybe finding a
novelist
at some point you could actually do this
into a book follow a character or two
yeah oh they could like sell easily see
but the thing is their biggest issue is
they would have to keep it
more like a textbook than an actual book
like like halo
had all that stuff but they followed
individual characters now that
worked because you had the master chief
you you weren't playing as
your guardian you were always playing as
an already established character
halo arbiter or not halo master chief
arbiter etc
you know so they could make books like
that and the books then followed both
those characters and the villains
and everything worked great because
there was narrative there was no mmo
your unique [ __ ] feel right right
how would you make a destiny book it
would have to be like a text yeah you
would
well or you as you said do it by
characters like hey they hissed like
cade yeah that that could work like you
could do a
history of kate like dude has
and zavala like what he went through to
get where he is i would read that
journey
you know that'd be cool yeah yeah now
he's kind of a well
he's a wimp or he's going to be a bad
guy we don't know which are both but
uh right now he's stuck in grieving yeah
so
but yeah like again like i'll be curious
if that new origin story is like
is that gonna tease what we're getting
but we'll see but
i am i would love to read that as well
yeah i even thought about that
it makes a lot of sense which one no
that having following individual
characters like because i was like maybe
but the more i think about like they
have a lot of story to them
i bet i bet they could hire at least at
least one or a team of novelists
to tackle characters like that yeah
flashlight
yeah or even like they kind of did with
oryx
with the books of sorrow but that's just
such a base thing that's nowhere near a
novel
you know like i would want to see the
villains yeah that'd be cool
what is it what is that cra son of a son
of a
son of a god and it'd be like crota
yeah or something like that would be
kind of cool
send him to the vex portal yeah when
come back a winner don't come back at
all
dad of the year right there
yeah got great siblings though so i mean
he's doing okay
yeah well man it has been
we did it we hit three hours so holy
crap um
yeah now we haven't done this for a
while but it has been an absolute blast
but i feel like we gotta let you
obviously work
for milan and that is by the way who we
are gonna go raid making sure he's still
online so
don't go anywhere i'm going to send you
guys over to milan games by the time we
are done since we got to do this in
proper fashion we're going to go raid
the man
we've been talking about for a while
anyway let's see so he's
playing halo right now he's supposed to
be playing titanfall
oh my god all right uh but before we go
we got to let you uh wrap it up
just let them know where they can find
you what you got going on anything
you're working on
any art projects any style changes
what have you got coming up let them
know where they can find all of your fun
stuff sir
right below me should be links to
twitter youtube and twitch
i'm also on instagram as gamma trap and
i have a website called gammatrap.com
and those are just the stuff i've got a
lot of prints
almost everything that i've made is on
print
at imprint and all of my stuff i've made
with mylan
is on metal display prints at our
display store both of which you can find
links to on my website
project wise i'm just we're just making
stuff constantly working on our youtube
lore stuff
uh right now i'm making the daughter of
kalas i'm gonna be finishing her up
tomorrow night
yeah so that was that's a blast i hate
drawing cabal but i don't mind drawing
this one
freaking tusk and looking all like that
alpha dragon
from power train dragon it's awesome
that's really cool that is dope i will
be looking for that one for sure
um man it has been an absolute pleasure
it's been a blast in half this one my
favorites ever been on
seriously like we we could probably keep
going and i can't believe
my food tension we have to be like okay
this is too long we are sorry um sorry
everybody about the food tangents but
apparently you know i'm a little crazier
than you thought so that's fine
uh but that cognito you're up sir
yeah man first of all salute the lord
gamma
for coming through you know what i'm
saying that drop of knowledge
absolute blast again if you guys are not
onto them please get on to him because
again
tremendous artwork versatile hour style
so cool and then
um yo shout out to like i said zavala
the betrayer and i have the hype
he's seeing the work with you and my
lame that's dope
i'm loving that whole angle has been
super pumped
now for beyond like even more learning
this information and seeing the visuals
with that so so do you sir that was
fantastic you already know me on twitter
lora cognito and our iowa podcast every
sunday is the lowest day
so check us out at 1pm eastern we will
have neogamespark
in the realm we're going to talk some
gaming his video same
video game history as well as some of
the latest stuff that's going on check
out um
there's a new game right now e i got a
game for you i don't know if you've seen
it it's called
black myth oh hell yes i've seen that
video bro
thing yeah yeah yeah there we go the
monkey dude right
yeah i was like yeah i was like dark
souls dark souls monkey man
and then goes crazy literally goes ape
sorry yeah
batman oh yeah man so we're gonna talk
about that we'll talk about um
for the sensation that is full guys
couple other things going on in the
gaming industry
check us out and of course yo please
again support thank you guys
supporting our lord's gaming.net really
means a lot website is growing we
finally
that's a new website quarter of a
million views it's just been the sky's
been the limit salute to the writers
thank you guys for sharing all that
stuff
and um yeah i mean you already know as
far as i love podcast
and of course the last word you know
that best damn destiny podcast most
people don't know about but we gotta
flex a little bit
he hates what i do but i got to do it
dave i love this show but salute to eve
man this is fun and again gamma thanks a
lot brother
next year hopefully when things get back
to the door we're going to get a gcx
beverage cheers and then we're going to
put condiments at the table and we're
going to watch each face as he tries
each one no
i'm going to put one put ketchup in my
shot glass right in front of you and
then i'll have a big glass
and i'm going to be over here with
tequila shot being like y'all are crazy
no no
that's my that's my drink of choice for
sure
if i'm gonna shoot if i'm gonna do a
shot i'm gonna do a shot it's probably
tequila and so if i'm gonna drink a lot
of salt
margaritas are amazing we down here
pickle juice you're gonna make me throw
up
ginger so i think miss gingerish will be
coming back she's having too much fun so
she's going in she's good i'll say he's
not watching
mistake with a1 i just want to see his
face and disgust with me
put anyone on something i just love it
if you get a cheap steak i but yeah
you've ruined a good steak i'm just
going to be pissed
we won't have i won't personally have
much time to get any good food
so i'll eat anything man at gcx if i'm
not sleeping
if i'm not at my booth if i'm not
drinking i'm eating [ __ ] food
absolutely i i i didn't know you at the
time but i
have actually have you recorded when i
did my walkthrough
when i did my walkthrough e yeah and i
went up to milan and you were right
there i was like have a trap i saw the
day i was like okay we're trying
to dave and you like it
it was a moment we had a moment you
didn't know about i'll show you the
video it's hilarious
i'm pretty sure i've got one of your
pieces of art sitting in this closet
over here i haven't hung any of that
stuff from last year because i don't
know where to put it all yet
who's who was one of your left the
scottish the scottish girl who was who's
that zoe what's her name no uh
that's there we go that's it she had i
was watching your last one she had my
gambit snake right behind her
oh cool yeah yeah fire
that's what's up that's what's up e i
could have found people find you if i
record a video of you jugging pickle
juice what would i
do um
for the win yeah you you have to be like
a that's a charity goal
sure yeah oh god
and you want to see i better have a
trash can nearby that or i'm gonna have
a chaser of tequila that might be the
way to do it
oh dude people just tequila doesn't
sound too bad you guys are all crazy
disgusting space that's what i paid
money for that all right
we wrap this thing up trying to
synchronize our words here so we're
going to see if we can do this you guys
it has been amazing
gamma thank you man if we can ever see
each other in person i'm just going to
at least meet you in the area but gcx
will happen hopefully at some point
either way
um but for everybody in chat you guys
have been awesome thank you very much
chat's been just on fire tonight giving
me crap if nothing else
but yeah episode 117 august 21st for us
tonight it has been
the last word